This is Jocko podcast number
84 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening,
gentlemen.
Your life expectancy from the day you
join your battalion will be precisely
three weeks.
The Florid mustached major who addressed
us at the small reinforcement camp,
a few miles from bay,
you obviously had misplaced,
had a misplaced sense of humor or he
should have been sacked on second thought.
He definitely should have been sacked.
Not that any of the dozen infantry Sabol
turns took the slightest notice of what
to us with a ramblings of an old fool.
He was probably no more than 40
the fourth battalion,
the Somerset Light Infantry was in one
29 brigade and was a prewar territorial
army battalion with close
links with Bristol and bath
in the United Kingdom till late June,
1944 it was a close knit unit which had
almost been decimated within a period of
48 hours
on 5th of July three
officers and 62 other ranks.
We're required as reinforcements.
Between the 14th and the 18th of July,
a further 12 officers of whom I was one
and 479 other ranks arrived and even
then the battalion was still below its
full strength of 36 officers and nearly
700 and CEO's and men.
This will give some idea of the appalling
level of infantry casualties which had
to be accepted in order to enlarge the
slender and vulnerable Normandy beach
head.
Because I had the had had previous
experience of six pounder anti tank guns.
The commanding officer lippy Lieutenant
Colonel Cg Lipscomb posted me as second
in command to the battalions anti tank
platoon, which consisted of six guns,
but my stay with the platoon were short
and I was quickly sucked into the real
infantry battle as commander of 18
platoon in d company on the 31st of July.
Immediately after the battle of brisk
Broussard d company had just lost their
commander Tim Braithwaite who lost a
foot and gained a military cross and 18
platoon their commander.
So that right is the beginning
of a book that we're
going to look at today.
It's called 18 platoon.
It's written by a guy named Sydney,
Jerry j, a r, y,
who was born in Essex in 1924 joined
the army in 1942 as a private soldier in
1943 he was commissioned
and from 19 from July of 1944 until
June of 1945 he served as the platoon
commander for 18 platoon.
And
the chances of survival for an infantry
subaltern in a rifle company during the
campaign in northwest Europe were slim.
Most survived for only a few weeks.
Sydney,
Jerry survived 10 months from July,
1944 when he took command of 18 platoon
in Normandy until the end of the war,
near Bremen in early
May of 1945 so this guy,
this is, this is amazing,
this guy, Sydney Jerry,
he's the only platoon commander in the,
any British second army to survive as a
platoon commander from Normandy to the
German surrender. One Guy, one guy,
and this is the guy.
Okay,
it's,
it's amazing.
And you're going to see that
his attitude is, I mean, the,
the lessons that he learned, he was
young coming in. Who's 20 years old,
20 year old platoon commander
coming in inexperienced,
kind of lived a sheltered life. You've
got to check out some pictures of him.
He has that look to, it looks like
he looks like you don't sheltered.
It looks like a little
young whippersnapper. Sure.
So we'll go back to the book here as he
breaks down what a platoon was at this
time. In 1944 the war establishment of
a British infantry platoon was 36 men.
It consisted of three rifles,
sections, each of 10 men,
including a Brendan gunner,
each commanded by a corporal
or sometimes a lance sergeant.
There was also a small
platoon headquarters with a
two inch mortar detachment,
a PR,
which was an anti tank weapon.
The platoon sergeant and the commanders,
Batman slash runner
on July 31st 18 platoon
consisted of 17 all ranks,
12 of them are more recent reinforcements.
Halal one 12 and brick Krista
guard had claimed the rest.
So, so think about that. You're
supposed to have 36 people
in your platoon,
and they have 17 of which
12 our replacements,
which means that 29 people
had had been casualties.
There's seven people that had been
either killed or wounded, or sorry,
seven people out of this 36 that hadn't
been killed or wounded that remained in
the platoon right now.
So that's what we're talking about here.
And again,
he's coming in no combat experience.
He rolls in and going back to the book,
I sensed instantly that he
tight grip was required,
particularly so,
because those few who survived Hill
one 12 had witnessed what was without a
doubt,
the most horrific tragedy that befell
the battalion during the entire campaign.
So he's about to explain what they had
been through. He wasn't there for it,
but he knew and he had heard
what they had been through.
And I'm gonna say that again.
This is the most horrific
tragedy for the entire campaign.
This is what they're coming off of, and
this is who he's going to take over for.
This is what they had been
through back to the book during a,
during a company night attack and one of
our soldiers had been hit in the lower
chest by a rifle or a machine gun,
bullet passing through his body.
It did not kill them outright.
Okay?
The bullets devilish course lay through
the soldiers webbing equipment pouch,
which contained a 77
phosphorous smoke grenade,
which exploded,
caught on barbed wire.
The poor soldier lay disemboweled for
all around to see his rising body,
uh,
smoking mass of burning phosphorus,
responding to his agonized screams
to put him out of his misery.
His platoon commander
shot him through the heart
and finally through the head after
the poor man's final frenzied, please
not there, sir. Through the head,
Doug proctor was witness to this
sublimely courageous incident,
which seared itself upon all our hearts.
Okay,
so that's what you're going to take
over for Jay. Can you do that? I mean,
is that like legal? You know, like
if they found out that that happened,
I have no idea what the
legal ramifications are.
But the moral weight on the shoulders
of the men that witnessed that is,
is unbelievably,
it's,
it's hard to imagine what that feels like.
Back to the book to the NCO Sergeant
Jim Kingston and Corporal Doug proctor
immediately reported to me and explained
forcefully and in great detail the poor
state of the platoon as they knew
it to be. So you've got these guys,
these are the senior
enlisted guys in the platoon,
Jim Kingston and Doug proctor and you're
gonna hear a lot about them and they're
coming to him. Here's this
new guy checking in and
they're coming to them and,
and they're, you know, telling him how,
what, what a bad state the platoon is in.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
While they did.
So I was conscious of being weighed up
was I fit to be their platoon commander.
They were responsible, anxious,
and discriminating owes,
that stands for non commissioned officer.
It's the senior enlisted guys.
And my apprenticeship
was to start immediately.
They were startled by my attire
previously warned by a young officer who'd
fought in Tunisia. That battle dress
was most unsuitable for Brat battle.
I'd come prepared in sand colored
corduroy trousers and a stout pullover.
Not on like that now
worn throughout the army.
Among my prejudices was an
acute dislike of steel helmets.
They gave me headaches on exercises and
England. I had been obliged to wear one,
but the surge of individualism,
which now engulfed me,
convinced me that this was an article
of equipment best left out of battle.
Okay,
so he's, he shows up and he's
Kinda dressed out of uniform,
doesn't want to wear his helmet.
He's wearing corduroy pants.
Back to the book battle schools in
England had insisted that off infantry
officers should wear the same
equipment and dress as their soldiers.
The idea being that they could not be
then be so easily identified by enemy
snipers. They also decreed that one
should carry a rifle or a stun gun.
Clearly this was ridiculous.
How on Earth could your own soldiers
recognize you in the heat of battle if you
went through such lengths to disguise,
he had the same,
the same attitude as lieutenant lead and
Korea that was wearing the orange vest.
Do you remember that?
So he could be identified
in battle by his own men.
That's what this guy's attitude is like.
I'm not going to dress like everyone else.
They need to be.
They need to know who that I'm out there.
How can they need to be able to see me
back to the book I dispensed with a rifle
or sten gone too because I'm hopelessly
short sighted and I did not fancy trying
to command a platoon while
got up like a Christmas tree,
meaning covered and a bunch of gear
as a concession to impending battle.
I sported a 45 Colt automatic
pistol with two spare magazines,
the 38 Enfield revolver.
Then general issue throughout the army
managed to combine total mechanical
reliability with complete ineffectiveness.
Once fired six shots from one at a
target pinned to apply with board.
None of which even penetrated the board.
Neither did I hit the target,
which gave me a little
confidence in this weapon.
The nine pounds I paid for the
cult proved a sound investment.
So there's a lot of people that like to
talk about what type of side arm there.
You've got a big proponent for
the Colt 45 yeah. The classic,
again,
important to remember that he's not even
carrying a rifle because he knows his
job asleep.
And I used to do it when we had seals,
seal leaders that would spend
too much time on their gun.
I would say,
hey,
you know what they used to carry in the
Marine Corps and the army if you were a
leader, you know what they
carry? They carry a pistol.
Okay,
so give me your rifle and we take it from
him. Like you, you need to be leading,
not shooting.
Hmm.
Leif talks about that a lot.
Oh yeah. It's very, you know,
life talks about his mentality, which was
he wants to shoot. Yeah. He's from Texas.
You know, he's, he wants to shoot
his gun and he realized, Hey,
I'm not here to shoot my gun.
Yeah. I'm here to, you know,
be at high pork and be off my gun
and leading. Yeah, that's my job.
And these guys took it to the point
where they're not even carrying a rifle.
Yeah. Now he's talking about a
senior leadership a little bit.
His enlisted leadership back to the book,
Jim Kingston was short,
quiet and shy with the shoe,
does have a countryman.
Although he had lived and
worked in Bristol all his life.
He barely raised his voice but had
total command over his section.
There was no argument with Jim that that's
another thing you'll find about this
book,
this book.
It takes so many stereotypes from,
from Sydney,
Jerry on down.
Like the stereotypes are just out the
window of the way this platoon was.
And there's a classic
example. You know, you've,
you picture the senior enlisted
guy, there's Bra, you know,
gunny highway scenario.
Not happening now he can now he talks
about Doug proctor back to the book.
Doug prop proctor.
Although a Summerset came
from Nottingham also short,
he was positive,
direct with unfailing common sense and
like Jim quietly dominated his section.
So there's another,
and I got to see some great leaders.
There's some guys that were in warranty,
you bruiser that were quiet when they
were in to your bruiser and when I was
putting them through their next
workup, I was thinking myself, hey,
are they going to be
able to step up and lead?
And that's exactly how they did it
right there. They were just like quiet,
professional and controlling,
but they run their mouth to get it done.
Hmm.
Back to the book, I had not previously
met any platoon like this one.
They were quiet,
fought ful,
and on abrasive soldiers there was
little swearing and there existed a
tranquility in their
relationships with one another.
Yeah.
Their eyes implored me not to fail them.
Two factors were immediately apparent.
Firstly,
the platoon required quiet
firm and confident leadership.
So that's a good assessment.
You can see these guys don't
need anybody yelling at them.
And here's the second point.
Secondly,
if I failed to use my imagination and
slavish Lee followed the battle school,
most of the platoon would not
survive another major battle.
So all the things he learned,
a standard typical stuff that he'd learned
that wasn't gonna work and it hadn't
worked. That's why they had so many
replacements come in back to the book.
In fact,
the problem that faced me with 18
platoon was identical to the one facing
General Montgomery,
our army group commander,
how to fight and defeat the cream of the
ss panzer divisions in the close normal
Normandy bull college and still retain
sufficient infantry rifleman to live and
fight tomorrow.
The problem was a difficult one.
Obviously I must set an example
and always lead from the front.
However,
if I became overeager and
got myself killed or wounded,
the whole object of my previous training
and my responsibility to my platoon
would be cast away. I would in
fact be letting down 18 platoon,
so he knows he's got to lead from
the front the time, same time.
He knows he's got to stay alive.
He knows you got to stay alive
and this Normandy fighting here,
he talks about normally d
being a defender's paradise,
meaning when you're on
the defense and Normandy,
it's W it's a paradise for the people
on Defense, which was the Germans.
Back to the book. We fought from one
hedge row to the next up, torturous,
overgrown sunken lanes,
ideal country for the German defender,
but appalling for attacking infantry.
However,
no arm but infantry could take and hold
the Norman depot cottage bill conscious
like a trees.
Shrubs mangled together.
It was here that I served
my apprenticeship and
the platoon developed its
character,
which despite constant depletion by
casualties over the coming 10 months,
it would retain until the end of the war.
It was also here that imperceptibly
I became possessive with 18 platoon.
It was mine to be guarded with an almost
maternal jealousy that resented all
criticism of my soldiers.
That's building at this point,
most important.
It was in the boat cottage
that I began to appreciate.
How vital is grip
grip on oneself,
grip on one soldiers and
grip on the situation.
Unlike characters in novels and films,
most men react nervously
to real battle conditions,
discipline and regimental pride,
our supports,
but indecisive moments of great danger.
The grip of the leader
on the led is paramount.
Infantry section,
platoon commanders must possess the
minds and hearts of their soldiers.
Strength of character is not enough
successful leadership in battle,
although complex any intangible always
seemed to me to depend on two factors.
Firstly, soldiers must have
confidence in their leaders,
professional ability.
And secondly they must trust them as men.
So there you go. They got to have
confidence in your ability and trust.
And this trust topic
comes up all the time.
And I use the word relationships
kind of interchangeably with trust.
I always have to remind myself to point
that out, that what I'm talking about,
relationships and building relationships
and business on the battlefield and
wife relationships, our trust,
that's what they are yet.
But we build a relationship
on trust. Yeah. And I guess
you could have, you know,
relationships that aren't built on trust
that those are like another thing. Oh,
I have a relationship with that guy.
But you know. Yeah. So, but that's not,
that's the one I'm talking about,
right? I'm a good relationships. Yeah.
Those are based on trust and
those are obviously the most,
the second most important thing to him.
So first is confidence in their
ability and second is trust.
I like this part. It helps too. If a
leader has the reputation of being lucky
field Marshall Montgomery place great
importance on the principle of making the
enemy dance to your tune.
Nowhere is this more important
than in platoon and company battle.
It is decisive because if
you do not dominate events,
your enemy will.
Okay.
There you go. That's Jujitsu right there.
Be First. Yeah. You gotta be first.
You got to dictate the pace.
You gotta you gotta be proactive.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Sound leadership like true love to which
I suspect it is closely related is all
powerful.
It can overcome the seemingly impossible
and it's effect on both leader and led
is profound and lasting.
Even after the passage of 40 years.
Brief mention of the battalions
finest officers and NCRS brings.
It brings a smile to the faces
of the survivors of my platoon.
There resentment of those who failed to
lead when it mattered most still runs
astonishing.
Lead deep.
Yeah.
So leadership can overcome
seemingly impossible.
This why leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield.
Mm.
Now he's going into his,
so that's kind of his assessment
and this is based on his experience,
which we're about to get into. Then he's
does more assessments, there's more, more.
He talks more about what he learns
about leadership as a whole,
but you have to kind of understand what
he went through and figured out where he
learned it from the first,
his first command in battle.
Here we go back to the book,
we were to attack this hill from the
west with the fifth wheelchairs on our
right and the fourth
wheelchairs in reserves. The,
the approach march to our forming up
place had been a nightmare of swirling
abrasive dust shelling and the stench
of exhaust fumes from the tanks which
transported us forward.
Okay.
We were due to attack at 1500 hours with
a company leading on the right and be
company on the left.
We followed B company B Company moved
off quickly with our company deployed
about 300 yards behind their forward.
Platoons had barely crossed the stream
when concentrated Spandau fire came from
the front and from both flanks.
So spend Al Fire.
This is kind of a generic term that the
Brits used for German machine guns and
they're primarily talking about the MG
42 which is a big belt fed machine gun.
Very similar to a modern,
what we have m 60 or mark,
48 machine going a big heavy belts,
belt fed machine gun,
which lays down the insane
amounts of suppressive fire.
So here we go. They're getting hit from
both flanks with these machine guns.
Back to the book, there must've been
about 12 machine guns firing at one time.
This devastating display of firepower
stopped the battalion dead in its tracks.
There was no way forward or
around it and no way to retire.
Some of the guns had engaged d company
over the heads of B Company and private
Morrison 18 platoon was killed.
So there's his first guy lost.
I like this. The way he starts
off this next sentence here.
First word powerless.
Hmm.
So he's in his first combat situations,
got one man killed and how's
he feel powerless. Here we go.
Powerless and crouching and a hedge row.
I tried to identify the
spanned out positions.
This proved impossible
as they still kept up.
They're crushing display of firepower.
In my ignorance,
I expected that the enemy machine gunners
would soon expand their ammunition.
They did not, nor did they in
dozens of subsequent battles.
So he's waiting for them to stop shooting.
They don't. It just keeps coming.
Captain Scammell commanding a
company was severely wounded.
Major Thomas Commanding
be company was killed.
Their companies were badly
caught up on our right.
The fifth wheelchairs had fared no better
with their CEO killed and casualties
mounting their attack.
Also foundered.
Okay.
As the afternoon turn to evening shelling
and mortaring increased much of it
passing over our heads.
This isolating us from the
Reserve Battalion so that
the Germans are mortaring
over their head so that the reserve
battalion can't get to them.
Shortly before dark,
a troop of tanks arrived,
one of which able to cross the stream
and give us some brave close support.
Undoubtedly it increased our morale,
but it was not enough to get
the whole attack underway again.
Any movement by B Company to our front
brought down instant and concentrated
Spandau fire.
The same applied to us a few
hundred yards to their rear.
Fortunately, the enemy did not
seem to have any anti tank guns,
so our armored friends
were comparatively safe,
but the fact remained that
about 12 span dose had halted.
A battalion attack without
are locating even one of them.
That's what suppressive fire does.
That's what,
that's what a big machine gun does.
You've got 12 big machine guns.
This stopping 700 people from moving.
That's called suppressive fire.
That's why you don't,
when you heard Roger Hayden talk
about how how many heavy weapons they,
how many machine guns they'd carry.
They,
I think they had nine out of
a platoon of 14 that's why
as dusk fell,
a new plan was made.
C and d companies would advance in
single file through a and B companies and
using the cover of darkness,
darkness infiltrate the enemy position.
Once through them we would climb to the
top of the hill and consolidate a cold
and damp miss descended,
which with fading light gave us welcome
cover but also wretched discomfort.
We were still in shirt
sleeves which became damp from
the sweat of our exertion.
Climbing the steep lower slopes
alert with pistol and hand.
I anticipated a sudden
brush with an enemy post.
Not a shot was fired by some miracle.
We passed right through their positions
without being to deck detected our luck
and changed
so you're going to see quite a bit of
that is as they what the Germans were
doing at this point defending hard,
but then instead of staying in dying,
in most cases they would retreat and so
they'd fight really hard for awhile and
then retreat and they advance
if they had an opportunity.
But you're going to see a
lot of that back to the book.
We now had to advance
across a large orchard,
so I deployed the platoon
with two sections up and
urged them forward as fast as
possible.
Suddenly in the middle of the orchard,
we came across a young girl in a clean
white dress sitting with her back to an
apple tree sketching.
Now I just talked about
this at the mustard,
the random things that happened in combat
and this is what I'm talking about and
how do you train for that?
How would you ever,
if you're running a battle problem to
train people, what are you going to do?
Put a white girl in a white dress and
the sitting with her back to a tree
sketching doesn't make any sense. How
do you deal with it? Back to the book,
she seemed quite oblivious to the mortar
fire in 18 platoons warlike appearance,
how to stop pretty young
girls from interfering with
battle had not been part of
my training as an officer,
Cadet nor headed appeared on the
curriculum of any battle schools,
which without exception had despaired
of my as an infantry soldier.
Fortunately,
there was a farm house beside the
orchard and it had a cellar where she was
persuaded to shelter.
While we got on with our battle,
I reported what had occurred to our
company commander who told me that I was
being quite ridiculous. Really,
Jerry, you're being absurd.
With that remark, I realized
that he had been a school master,
a breed with whom I had been in
conflict until quite recently,
a breed with whom I'd been in
conflict with until quite recently.
So this guy has the,
the attitude of a schoolmaster,
which in England is a little bit
different and especially in the 1930s and
forties you know the strict, I think of
a pink Floyd, you know the headmaster.
How can you have any pudding if
you don't eat? You meet that guy.
That's what he's comparing him to.
His next sarcastic remark,
I would be obliged, Jerry, if you
would kindly get on with the war.
He gave me a little indication of
what he wanted my platoon to do,
nor did it inspire confidence.
We were still over 200 yards from
the meadow surrounded by cornfields,
which was the company's objective.
And now became apparent that our company
commander had an academic and detached
attitude of mind, which made it quite
impossible for him to come in the company.
So the company,
the company commander is not in the game.
There's one thing to be detached from
your emotions to make sure you're not
getting caught up in the
mayhem was another thing to
be so detached that you're
not even aware of what's going on.
And actually I had a name for this
when I was running training battlefield
aloofness is what I called it.
Cause we'd get these guys,
you get these guys and we'd be running
these crazy battlefield problems on them
and it'd be not to be crazy. And you'd
go, I remember one time there's a,
the the task unit commander,
there's all this mayhem going on.
The platoons are getting overrun and
the people are getting, you know,
shot with paint ball and they're
not hitting their objectives.
And I walk over to the company commander.
He's sitting in a Humvee, or sorry,
the the t you commander,
the troop commander.
He's sitting in a Humvee and I like the
windows up because they're bullet proof
windows, but he does want to get
shot with paypal. The windows up,
he's just sitting in there.
He's got his headset on.
I was radio like knock on
the door. I'm like, hey man,
you know what's going on out
there? He's like, well I'm,
I'm, I'm trying to gather that
information right now. And I'm like, Bro,
you ain't gonna gather
anything here but dust. Yeah,
you need to get out there and make
something happen. Because his idea was,
you know, I need to be detached, which I
talk about being detached all the time,
but there's a difference between
being and as you see the same thing in
businesses where the,
the,
the boss or the leader has no idea what's
happening on the ground floor. Right?
He doesn't know what the,
the workers are doing.
So he's so far to attach that he's,
he's, you know, let them eat cake. Right.
That's where that's where this guy is
that because what they just in a way just
depend on them to just
handle it on their own.
They think they're going to handle it on
their own, which a good attitude to have
until they can't handle it anymore.
Right, right. Once they can't, once a,
once a team or a platoon or a business
unit can't handle it on their own and
they're failing. You have to get, you have
to go do your job. You have to step up.
You have to step down as leader.
You have to get in there and
square that stuff away. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's that without the get
there part, right. It's just like,
all right, call me when
it's done. And, and,
and the problem is somebody has got to
sort these problems out. Yeah. Yeah.
They're, they're, they're real.
Yeah. And they're not getting better.
And you might take you a minute to
go, okay, wait a second. This, these,
these problems aren't getting better.
What should I do?
Once you realize that
they're not getting better,
you've got to get in
there and make it happen.
Yeah.
This guy's not doing that.
Back to the book,
he'd be behaved like a supercilious
umpire on an exercise in England at any
moment.
I expected him to admonish me for bad
tactics and the school boy and me feared
that I might be sent to the
headmaster for a beating.
So they continue on.
We seize the highest point which face
the enemy and the other platoons quickly
deployed to give all around a fence of
the other flanks after being mortared.
The company required no encouragement
to dig in. It's a real motivator.
Getting mortared will make
you shovel hard and yeah,
the company commander walked
round the platoon positions,
eyeing everyone with distaste,
nothing pleased him and he suddenly
announced that he must sleep,
which he did in my slit trench.
Getting not a good feeling
about this company commander.
Just looking at everyone like
negatively and then all of
a sudden he wants to sleep.
I don't like this guy.
And of course he sleeps in in my trench.
Now this is good. There's another
officer that's there that's present,
a guardian angels watching over
us in the guise of Dennis Clark.
Dennis some years older than
me was exceptionally kind
to me and tolerant of my
immaturity. Pay Attention.
This is good. He took my,
took me by the arm a few
paces away from my platoon.
Who the hell is in command
of this shambles? Sunny,
I muttered the unconvincing explanation
that it was our company commander
looking me straight in the eye.
He drew a deep breath,
which managed to express
both exasperations at my
explanation and sympathy with
my predicament.
You and I know that he is not.
So what are you going to do about it?
Okay.
I asked him if I should take command
his expression hardened. Yes.
You bloody well.
Should
some demonstration of loyalty to my
wretched company commander was obviously
required.
I blurted out that he was really a school
master and not a professional soldier,
so he's kind of defending him.
Dennis put his arm around my
shoulder and whispered in my year,
so was eyes sunny,
so
that's awesome.
The company commander is not leading
and this this guy, Dennis Clark,
who I think he's, um,
artillery. Gunner pulls.
This guy's a scientist, bro. You better
take charge of this. And you better do it.
Quick. Back to the book, we were
now, well dug in on our objective.
The company commander was still asleep.
Dennis was arranging
defensive fire tasks for me.
I hit assumed command of d company without
a word passes in between our company
commander in me in practice. It may
not the slightest difference because,
because like a bad
preparatory school master,
he saw his role as one of
examination and criticism.
Yeah.
This he continued to do despite
the incredulous stairs of the NCS.
So he's taking charge and and he hasn't
even said anything. He's just done it.
He just took charge and all the guy, the
guys continue to walk around, get stare,
glared everyone. But that doesn't
matter. So this is a classic example.
Your leaders not leading. I, I've
given this answer. It's so many times,
but this is a classic.
This might be one of the best examples.
Your leaders not leading. That's fine.
Good step up and lead yourself. Hmm.
Okay.
Back to the book by Don.
The enemy had retired and elements of the
battalion moved forward to consolidate
and strength and d companies position.
The whole operation was very amateur.
There was no doubt that the new company
commander could not command a company in
battle,
nor could I who is just beginning to
master the rudiments of commanding couple
tune.
He was removed within a few hours.
I think Dennis had
something to do with it,
but he was not the kind of man to
confide in 20 year old sub alternates.
So that's another classic thing
right there is that this Guy Dennis,
who was another uh,
officer probably went and said,
get this Guy Outta here,
get this company commander out of here.
But when he does it,
the company commander gets removed and,
and he doesn't say anything to
Sydney. Jerry, he doesn't, you know,
ratted out or brag about
or make a big deal.
He doesn't say anything just happens.
It's like when I had a mutiny and my
platoon and the commanding officer's like,
no, we're not firing anyone.
You guys get Outta here.
Shut your mouse and go back to work. And
we were like, okay. And then a few days,
like a week later he got fired, but we,
it wasn't because of us as far as we know.
Right. Like no one's anything.
We just knew he got fired.
Yeah. Well, what reason?
We knew we had something to do with it,
but same thing.
So you don't need to create
a distrust in disloyalty and,
and not even just those words, but you
don't need to create drama. Yeah. Right.
Don't treat the drama.
Yeah.
That guy's going to going somewhere is
getting built it somewhere else. Hey,
you guys won everybody. Yeah. Yeah. We're
not doing that. We're not doing that.
We're not up our own ego
by disparaging someone else's. Let's worry
about the whole team. How's that sound?
Sounds like a good idea to me.
Back to the book,
I now have little doubt that for
the first two months in Normandy,
we lack two things.
Comprehensive and imaginative training
and personal experience of battle.
We were all so seriously
handicapped by our casual attitude.
Too many junior officers did not think
for themselves and persistently relied on
the narrow teaching of battle schools
whose dogma had assumed the proportion of
holy writ.
So whatever he was taught,
he was taught that that's the
only way you can ever do it.
And these guys that I've talked about
this many times on the, on the podcast,
the goal when I was running training was
to actually get the people to think it
wasn't sure. You have to establish the
baseline standard operating procedures.
That's great and those
need to be rock solid.
But once those things are established,
you need to make people understand that
you don't always follow them and you
need to call off a piece of that standard
operating procedure to insert some
other thing and bring in another per
standard operating procedure and mix and
match them so that you get
something that's effective.
You need to think that's what a leader
needs to do at leader needs to think back
to the book.
The British infantry platoons and
companies were overtrained and bored stiff
with basic infantry tactics, which
as far as they went, we're good.
Much of this training unfortunately
had been in the hands of battle school
instructors who themselves lacked
battle experience and imagination.
These tended to become pedagogues,
disciples of ds directing staff solution
about which no argument could be
tolerated. So DSS is that he'd
be, he mentioned it a bunch.
It's like that's their
solution. The directing staff,
you can't argue with them.
They're the, they're the
cadre. Yeah. Possibly.
Like most of our entry infantry,
they suffered some consequences of
the prewar shortage of creativity.
Intelligent regimental officers,
too.
Few of them were professionally
dedicated to the extent that they could
visualize how battles will be fought and
identify the problems that might arise
when planning them.
They seem to lack the capacity to think
relentlessly through these things until
solutions were found.
Much of their time had been spent
policing the British empire. Also,
unlike the Germans,
we British instinctively
avoid displays of keenness.
The enthusiast, particularly if he
is innovative, isn't embarrassment.
Thus the battlefield became our teacher
and inevitably it exacted a grim price
in blood and time.
So as you're training,
you got to push yourself hard.
You've got to put yourself in situations.
I don't care what you're training for.
I don't care if you're training for
combat in a seal platoon, in an army,
infantry platoon,
or if in the business world and
you're training your leaders to handle
situations or you're training
your customer service
reps to handle situations,
no matter which one of those you're in,
you need to push people hard.
You need to put them in
worst case scenario so that
they need to learn how they
need to learn how to think
to get out of those problems.
Okay.
I recall with embarrassment and incident
at 45th infantry divisional battle
school during the spring of 1944 and
exceptionally tall and good natured
Canadian officer had been sent to the
school to give a talk on the street
fighting. He had experienced
natally. It was an interesting talk,
but some of his advice ran contrary
to that being taught in the school.
Okay.
When the lecture was over,
the chief instructor with
insulting condensation,
thank this shy and kindly man for a
vivid word picture and turning to the
student's warned us that at as this
officer's experience was probably unusual.
We had best not stray
from the DAS solution.
Okay.
As taught at that school.
So you've got to combat veteran coming
back with experience from street fighting
in Italy.
Okay.
And he'd come back with some different
tactics and they tell him that you don't
listen to that guy.
That's just a rare case.
Closed mind will get you killed.
Yeah.
This is starting to talk
about their overall sort of
formulation of combat plans
and how they operated.
Back to the book.
The most successful actions by 18 platoon
were fought without the support of
artillery or armor.
We had learned in a hard school
how to skirmish, infiltrate,
and edge our way forward,
the right or left flanking platoon attack.
So beloved of the battle school staff
would rarely succeed in the Normandy
bocage.
I remember with horror being locked
into timetables of meticulously planned
large battles, these invariably
left the junior infantry commander,
no scope for exploitation.
If you found a gap in the enemy defenses,
adherence to artillery program,
which rarely could be altered,
effectively stopped any
personal initiative.
So what that's saying is you have these,
the artillery that's going to drop bombs,
they're going to bomb or strike with
artillery at certain regions and certain
times.
So Lee,
you might see the enemy running away
and you have a chance to gain a superior
tactical position,
but you can't because you know that
that's where the bombs are going.
That's where the artillery is gonna
be hitting in the next 12 minutes.
So you can't go.
So now you sit and wait.
So he got locked in by that
back to the book. To me,
the preparations for these battles assumed
the demented proportion of a Koffka
liked nightmare ballet in
which the anonymous they
ordained that we must perform
a choreographed at ritual dance.
Mccobb I felt trapped and helpless.
No Solo parts were written into the score,
nor was there scope for small groups
of performers and this man of ballet of
machines undoubtedly far shadows from the
psalm that the battle of Somme clouded
my emotions.
But instinct told me that this kind
of show would be unlikely to succeed.
The irony was that this support was
planned and given to the infantry.
Would the best of intentions.
The Psalm had cast its shadows on our
artillery and armored commanders both
genuinely believed that their hands,
they,
that in their hands they had the
panacea which would protect us,
the infantry from the terrible slaughter
of 1916 instead they put us in a
straight jacket. So very
interesting viewpoint. And,
and it's something that we need
to pay attention to because
you've got to be flexible.
You gotta be flexible and that's exactly
what he's talking about. And these,
they would make these plans that were
so comprehensive and there was no,
you weren't allowed to
deviate from the plants.
And when you're not allowed to deviate
from the plans and it's something starts
going differently than what you expected,
you're trapped.
Yeah.
Telephone
back to the book,
far too much time had been spent fitting
the infantry and armor junior leaders
into the big picture and too little
time spent training them and stimulating
their imagination and initiative and
individual resourcefulness to probe,
draw conclusions, infiltrate and exploit
weaknesses in the enemy's dispositions.
So He's,
he's criticizing this lack of initiative,
lack of creativity and the training
to get that initiative and creativity
back to the book after the 1st of August,
18 platoon never failed in any attack.
Sometimes we took a little
longer than planned,
but we always got there
in the end in defense,
we never lost one yard of ground,
nor did the enemy ever
penetrate our platoon position.
And we always dominated no
man's land with our patrols.
Whether persistent patrolling
is always sound policy,
I will argue elsewhere.
Okay,
so he's saying once he kind of figured
it out, they didn't lose any more.
They didn't lose any attacks and
they didn't give up any ground.
It talks about the armor.
Our armor was accused of being tiger shy,
meaning scared of the Tiger
tanks and the Germans.
And I don't wonder why the devastation
caused by a single hit of an 88
millimeter armor piercing shell
needed to be seen to be believed.
And this is an overall statement
for the infantry and armor,
the British Second Army,
the sheer ferocity of the fighting
in Normandy came as a salad tour.
Solitary shock for which they
were in some ways unprepared.
So it was devastating for these guys.
Now we start pushing out out of uh,
out of normality and pushing into the CNE.
Okay,
and here we go. They're
pushing in the next day, 28,
August d company occupied a Hara court.
This is the only operation of war that
I ever known to go precisely as planned,
are supporting field regiment softened
up the objective with their 25 pounders,
the company advanced over Open Farm
Land and immaculate formation and
consolidated exactly on time.
The only thing lacking was an enemy
total bag,
one days to German,
one dead German and one dead hair rabbit.
Right.
So the only one that ever went well was
when there was no enemy to fight against.
There was, there was two
Germans, one of them was dead,
the other one was dazed
and that was their,
their last battle in France.
Back to the book experience in Normandy
had removed anxieties regarding
commanding and under strength platoon.
So he hasn't had enough man.
He's supposed to have 36, he's had
like 17, 18, 19. In the attack,
particularly at night.
Apple tune at full strength is
just too big to maneuver quickly.
Three rifle sections of about 20 above
about seven men each plus headquarters
was ideal in defense. It was a different
matter. The more riflemen on the ground,
the better or short stay in lamence Sal
Milan gave me time to think the first
opportunity to do so since I
took command of 18 platoon.
It also gave me time to meet and talk with
other young officers in the battalion.
It was then that I realized that
18 platoon was no ordinary platoon.
It had some undefinable magic,
no corals,
little swearing. Despite the war.
That was the, despite the war,
there was something peaceful about it.
A helping hand was always
available for anybody.
The emotional links were from and true.
I was a happy man,
so he realizes and once he starts
talking to the other platoon commanders,
he's got this really special platoon
that gets along great and he's,
he realizes it
back to the book.
No young officer can command a platoon
in battle on his own. In Normandy.
I'd seen platoon commanders served by
poor NCO struggling to gain some semblance
of control over their
bewildered and frightened men.
I'd also seen platoons with good end
CEOs go to pieces in the hands of an
indifferent officer,
Jim Kingston,
Doug proctor and Owen Cheesman set
this standard and tone for 18 platoon.
Without them,
I as the platoon commander would have
joined the ranks of so many poor young
officers who never achieved grip.
Okay.
Now
going to
another and he's putting together
another plan as they're advancing it,
and obviously this is a long book.
I'm doing an abridged version,
hitting some highlights. You should
get the book. I obviously get the book,
buy the book
back to the book at Zero 400 hours
on 24th of September. Douglas,
this is the new company commander Douglas
Douglas held along Oh group by candle
light in the cellar of the farmhouse at w,
which much to his annoyance,
I kept falling asleep.
We were ordered to advance
straight eastward down a
narrow country lane from the
orchard to the main road and consolidate
after the Oh group and [inaudible]
group is what they call it.
Like when they're,
when they're officers get together and
pass the word and they called Oh group.
After the o group,
I made myself unpopular by asking
why were advancing towards an area of
considerable German opposition when my
patrol had found a better route by which
we might outflank the enemy. So
that, so he's saying, Hey, wait, why?
Cause at his Pulitzer,
all his platoon had been out on a
patrol and found a better route and he's
asking why and he kind of gets shut down.
I was just 20 years old at the time.
And even then I knew I was incapable of
disputing orders without giving offense.
We started at zero 600 hours, two platoons
leading on either side of the track,
the third falling in single file down
the track itself on either side where the
small holdings were small holdings,
a few allotments and bungalows
surrounded by small picket fences.
But platoons advanced through the gardens
and vegetable patches and passed on
either side of the bungalows, the rear
section searching each one quickly
and while they're searching,
these little bungalows is there on patrol.
They find this back to the book
during one of these hurried searches,
one section found a Dutch family,
the Wittich's father,
mother, son and daughter,
riddled by Schmidt's or fire.
That's a German machine gun.
They lay an awkward postures of Def amid
their ransacked home visit from the SS.
No tears came,
nor did they come a half an hour later
when we came upon the charred wreckage of
an American Dakota,
it had carried us parachute troops to
the 82nd airborne division and they're
torn and burnt bodies littered the orchard
like charred and mutilated rag dolls.
Okay.
There was a further irony
attached to the front window and what
remained of the Dakotas cockpit was a tiny
teddy bear untouched by flames
two months before a lonely teddy bear
and an impersonal pool of blood had
brought forth tears.
Now I was collected and objective when
faced within the span of 30 minutes with
an atrocious murder and
mass carnage by fire.
And he's referring there in
the beginning of the book,
one of his first experiences,
he's by a slit trench and there's a dead
guy soldier in it and there's a little
teddy bear. And, and for some
reason, you know, he's young,
he's inexperienced and it gets,
gets, makes him super emotional.
He starts crying and, and
now he's a little further in
the war. He sees, you know,
this horrible murdered
family and these tragically,
you know,
burned and killed paratroopers and he's
able to detach emotionally from it.
Back to the book,
the enemy decided to make life
unpleasant for us as possible by sudden
unpredictable concentrations
of heavy artillery.
Right in the middle of our company area.
We called them stocks.
So he's going to use that word.
It just means we're getting bombed.
One of these shells unfortunately
fell right into one of 16 platoon slit
trenches.
No trace remained of the two
men that were manning in it.
Manning a Bren in my platoon,
Lance Corporal Jack Lee and private Peter,
filmer or buried in the trench.
They shared other members of their
section quickly dug them out unharmed,
very dirty and remarkably cheerful.
The self propelled guns,
increase their activities,
filling the sky above the company
with ugly black air bursts.
Yeah,
they could place these with uncanny
accuracy to burst about 25 feet above the
road junction,
outside company headquarters,
the casualties mounted company Sergeant
Major Sammy Jones and spot Martin.
The jeep Burke driver were
both hit outside company HQ.
It was Sammy Jones who committed
the battalion's only atrocity.
Late one summer evening as the shadows
from high trees and hedges fell across a
small field and Normandy.
We took some young Waffen Salt
Waffen SS soldiers prisoner.
One of them are short, stocky, and fair.
Youth of about 18 proved insultingly
truculent seizing the young lout by the
scruff of his neck. Samari roared. You
can take that Glenn out of your eyes,
my boy, and putting the
wretched youth across his knees.
He gave his backside a sound wacky
that is legit. And that's
again, uh, you know, Sydney.
Jerry and he talks about how
proud he is that his men,
it's men's behavior is so
upstanding throughout this
whole miserable experience.
And even when they see atrocities
committed, like by the SS,
they still maintain their discipline
and their character. And this is,
this is what he does. Oh,
you, you're a little punk kid.
I'm going to spank you.
You tough little SS soldier can
put over the knee and spanked.
So after the attack, so
now there's, this is again,
this is happening after one of
these attacks and, and the whole,
the whole basic premise of
this book is attack, rest,
attack, rest, attack,
rest. So as I'm reading,
I'm kind of picking out some of the
attacks that they're going on and they're
just moving through France and then
through Germany. That's what it is.
I should have explained that earlier.
Uh, but this is after one of the attacks.
It's interesting.
He says this smiling faces vanished.
And the gray look returned once
more men walked with one ear,
cocked in the air for approaching
shells and with a slight stoop.
If you remember what I remember I was
talking about JP and I was talking about
how like you'd see guys, they have
this natural little stoop. Yeah, yeah.
That's what he's talking about.
And Jp didn't happen. No stoop.
Jp standing up like you stupid.
He was not. Yeah, he was stupid.
He you standing up ready to get some.
But these guys as an,
it's contrast because when they're on
the attack, they go into like JP mode.
They're standing up straight,
the ready to get some,
but then once they're on the defense
and they're just waiting to get shelled,
they start to stoop.
They started crouch a little bit.
He continues back to the book. The jokes
began to Peter out and the cheerful,
good morning sir ceased when I went
around the platoons at stand too.
Morale was always hired during an attack,
sitting around and being shelled is
not an occupation to be recommended.
So there's a good lesson there.
If do you or your team is
being defensive about things,
your morale is going to go down
because you're waiting to get hit.
So go out and hit somebody, you know,
go on the attack. Don't wait around.
Don't let your morale drown.
Hmm.
Here's another attack. Back to the
book. Scrambling out of the Colbert,
we set a fast pace up the side of
the road to a company's positions.
This immediately brought
small arms fire down on us,
but by then we were then 200 yards
of their slit trenches. So on.
We ran as fast as we could being soaked.
I began
to steam my boots,
squelched and seem to drag me back,
calling it my feet as it a bad dream and
stopping me from reaching the inviting
cover of the slit trenches.
A company was dug in with two platoons
forward in an orchard face to face with
the enemy who were in dykes
only a few yards beyond.
The third platoon was to the right rear
protecting the open flank and company
headquarters to the left rear
centered on some farm buildings.
It was to these farm buildings that we
ran hurling ourselves onto the straw on
the barn floor.
We lay panting and gasping for breath.
John a cock, a company commander
appeared round the door of the barn.
He looked haggard and ward.
I doubt he had slept for a week.
The whole company area was covered
by the most intense Spandau fire and
defensive and the defensive battle
here was one of fire supremacy,
which the Germans had undoubtedly one,
a company's morale was low.
They had just lost Harry Barnes,
one of the platoon commanders who refusing
to take cover strutted about in his
usual manner.
He took a complete burst of
Spandau fire under the arm.
Harry was an amazing and fearless fellow
who didn't care a damn for anything.
Even after the burst hit him,
he still lived for about three hours.
The men respected Harry and with
their idol shot down in front of them,
they were very jumpy.
Okay.
Nother time you have to watch
out for morale, obviously.
Now,
okay,
if you remember,
this book started in the summertime
and now we're starting to get
towards fall and this,
this was something I'd
never thought about before.
When fall comes, you know the sun
is up for a shorter period of time.
Three. Here we go. Back to the book.
The knights became longer and
the dawn's gray and chilly.
The sunsets were red and vivid and the
days though beautiful shortened rapidly
as the knights lengthened the hours of
stag lengthened and with them the mental
and physical fatigue of the company,
so
they have to stay after, stay up, you
know, go rotate through watches at night.
You just don't get to sleep the whole
time. So if it's, if it's dark for longer,
you got to stay awake longer at night.
So it's starting to wear
on the company itself.
Back to the book, there
was, there is one incident,
small room that when remembered by
itself in a life of such incidents,
but very,
but to me very vivid in my platoon,
there was a young lad
aged 18 named Biddle.
He was slight of build fair
and looked a mere child.
He had a pleasant personality
and it was liked by everyone.
He had joined the company at Lawmen Sell
Milan after we had crossed the CN at
Vernon in August
one morning.
There was a crack in a
short interval of silence.
Soon the shout went out. Stretcher
bearers echoed through the orchard.
I ran towards the commotion and saw
Biddle writhing in agony on the ground.
Okay.
At first he looked on hurt,
but as I tore open his tunic,
I saw clear wound through his
abdomen coming out by a spine.
He soon became numb and
was no longer in pain,
but was very frightened and shivered.
We dragged him back behind the house and
applied field dressings to his stomach
and his back in case the
wound started to bleed.
Is young life solely ebbing from his body?
Our stretcher bearers quietly
and reverently carried him away.
The scene is now to poignant to
remember without shedding a tear
after Biddle had been evacuated,
the morale of the platoon dropped.
He had been hit while standing in his
slit trench by a sniper at least 300 yards
away.
And you know, it's, it's interesting,
and I didn't go into this part,
but there's a part earlier
in the book where he,
he basically
disparages somewhat the use of snipers
and he talks about how they usually
don't gain you anything tactically.
Okay.
But it's interesting what it does to
the morale of apple tune, isn't it?
Okay.
And He, you know, he doesn't complete. No,
he, he, he explains that there's usage.
Then there's,
believe me,
there's probably no bigger believer in
the use of snipers in the world than me,
but it's interesting, you know, he, he
basically, you can tell he's a very, uh,
a guy with,
you know,
this extremely high moral character
and he kind of gets the feeling when he
explains it that,
you know,
he didn't feel comfortable with sniping
because people aren't expecting it.
There's not a battle happening. He
felt like he was a cheap shot. Hmm.
Interesting. But it's interesting the
effect that it actually has on his platoon
in this moment
here. We're going to get to a point,
he's got, Germans are in a dyke,
they're just ahead of it. 18 platoon
and 18 platoon is kind of pin down.
And remember this character from earlier,
Dennis Clark, Dennis Clark was the,
was the guy that pulled
him aside and said, hey,
you need to take Amanda this company.
Well, like I said, Dennis Clark,
or I thought I remembered I was right.
Dennis Clark was a,
was an artillery guy that
called in artillery, so here
we go. Back to the book,
I was saved by Captain Dennis Clark Mc,
our team gunner.
Dennis had a virtuoso
touch where 25 pounders,
we're concerned sniping with one
gun that should get the buggers out.
He said with total confidence
moving his 19 set into my,
that's a radio moving as 19
set into my platoon position.
No easy task and daylight.
He gave us a display of the most brilliant
professionalism we had come to expect
from the 94th field regimen by firing
with only one gun and making his main
point of impact beyond the
dike containing the Germans.
He slowly decreased the d range yard
by yard until one shell exploded in the
dike.
Out came five very wet and
shaken pans are granted deers.
During this episode,
all the platoon had to remain in the
bottom of their slit trenches because
Dennis shells came over our
positions with minimum clearance.
I doubt if any experienced
infantry officer would deny
that the royal artillery
during the Second World War where the
most professionally competent people in
the British army.
So again,
an interesting dichotomy because in
the beginning he talks about how the
artillery can track them because it's
being used in this broad plan that's
locking in where there's no deviation.
But here he's talking about how
brilliant it is because he's directly
coordinating with it.
He's explaining to the artillery
officer where to put those rounds,
what the problem is, and then letting
the artillery officer's solvent.
So there's a dichotomy there. Just like
there's a dichotomy with the snipers
back to the book.
After a few more days in the orchard,
we were becoming increasingly exhausted
and are fighting efficiency deteriorated.
This condition existed not only in my
company but throughout the battalion.
Consequently, the news of a move
back to rest came as a colossal,
colossal relief to us all,
but we did not know who is going
to take over our positions.
The takeover was to be at night and was
to be carried out as quickly as possible.
If the enemy discovered it,
a determined attack could cause
endless confusion and slaughter.
During the late afternoon of
one particularly unpleasant day,
Douglas appeared that's
a company commander,
appeared with an American captain and two
lieutenants from a parachute battalion
of the hundred and
first airborne division.
They pad it around the company Area and
they're rubber soled boots with the eyes
or the whole company following them,
so the hundred and first is
coming in to relieve them
having record ordered our area,
the Americans returned to the company
HQ to discuss administrative points for
the takeover.
The plan was for the American company
commander to bring his company down the
main road in single file
along the edge of the ditch.
When the head of the column
reached our company Hq,
it would be met by guides from each
of our pl tunes to lead the American
platoons, their positions. As
soon as they were on the ground,
our platoons were withdraw
and assemble on the road.
This may sound simple in practice at,
but at night in close contact with
the enemy, it certainly was not.
This type of operation leaves to
companies particularly vulnerable.
During the handover,
a determined enemy could attack and
turn the operation into a massacre.
This is one of,
and I've said this before on the podcast,
so one of the hardest things to do is
link up with friendly forces on the
battlefield and if you're under fire,
it's, it's even harder. So this one,
they're trying to do it, not under
fire, trying to sneak in, make it happen
back to the book.
The rest of the day was spent packing,
making sure the enemy noticed
nothing of this anti activity.
We put our spare rounds ammunition
onto the carriers with great coats and
blankets.
The whole afternoon was strangely quiet.
There was no activity from the
enemy and we in turn kept quiet.
The Sun went down and made a fiery sky.
Looking east,
the sky was threateningly gray.
I went around,
I went round my position too with Sergeant
Kingston before the Americans arrived.
All my men look tired and
could hardly muster a smile.
As I went from slit the slit,
many had contained two men
and now contained only one
together with some Momento
of his former mate,
a mess tin or a blood stain jacket,
even a packet of cigarettes,
wet and limp with do.
I wondered how many more momentos
would be there when the Americans were
relieved.
About an hour later,
the Americans arrived. They loomed
up in the darkness by the road side,
padding along and the rubber
soled boots without a whisper.
I thought at the time what splendid
troops they were and how excellent their
equipment.
I was particularly impressed by the silent
and quick way they were led by their
squad commanders to our section positions.
So
there come the Americans to relieve him.
The hundred and first Airborne Division
who's just outstanding soldiers.
They're just awesome
and we worked with them.
It'd be one of my platoons in Ramadi,
worked with,
lived with them the first of
five oh six the band of brothers,
and you can tell they're the reputation
that the guys in Ramadi upheld that
standard in every possible way.
But it's rooted all the way
back to the soldiers right here.
Sounds like this is what struck me when
I read that I was like all this, this,
that,
that tradition of excellence in that
unit has gone from World War II,
from these guys right here,
and it's that same attitude that I saw
with guys and Ramadi, this same attitude.
Hmm.
All right.
Now he makes a statement here
about this whole big operation,
which was called market garden,
which was this giant
operation to try and cut off.
The Germans sees multiple bridges.
I can give us three bridges they
were trying to seize and it,
it didn't reach its full effect.
It wasn't like a complete mission success.
They didn't achieve every
objective that they wanted to.
So here we go. Back to the book.
Market Garden was a sad operation.
Complete success coming so close
at a stroke.
The war in Europe could have been
finished in 1944 undoubtedly,
mistakes were made both by
the first airborne division,
particularly their planners,
and also by 30 core and there
was no shortage of bad luck.
However, in my experiences,
in my experience,
most battles are riddled with
misfortunes and mistakes.
And the story of the sort
found in this operation,
it was not a failure because the ground
was taken and a prerequisite to both
operation veritable and
the Rhine crossing. So it
wasn't like a total failure.
Back to the book.
I'm convinced that had the supreme
commander General Eisenhower Given Market
Garden,
the unqualified support that it justified,
it would have totally succeeded despite
its crop of tactical errors and planning
and execution.
I suppose it was just one more casualty
of the American mania for dispersal of
effort.
However,
it was without a doubt the most exciting
and imaginatively planned battle in
which 18 platoon ever fought.
And I'm proud to have taken part.
So he's talking about folks of effort.
He's talking about you.
If you spread yourself out too thin,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna make it happen.
We call that prioritize and execute.
What's the biggest priority?
Let's put our resources there.
Hmm.
They didn't do that and therefore
didn't get a full mission success. Now,
of course, what resources were
there? What was available?
There's no one has on limited
resources. No one, if you have that,
you have no issues, right?
Yeah. And you're just crushed
problems with manpower.
All right.
So now they're moving beyond
market garden and planning,
uh, that actually
planning. He's planning a,
a patrol through a village.
Back to the book battle school teaching
at the time prescribed a strength of 12
to 20 for a fighting patrol.
Here again,
my instincts and experience did not
conform to their teaching. He's a rebel.
How can you command and control
that number of men in the dark,
particularly in a skirmish?
Douglas, the company commander,
tolerant of the absent
absency of my opinions
on these matters left the planning to me.
So cool.
Douglas's little these
centralized command. Did you
figure out your plan then?
I like this.
The composition of the patrol I based
on personalities and not on a battle
school, they're ordained
number. So imagine that you're,
you're planning based into on the
personalities of the individuals.
You have the countryside
being comparatively open.
I decided to take a Bren gun being steady.
Williams and filmer would
fill the bill admirably.
If we ran into trouble,
they could provide covering fire for any
assault we might make or if things went
badly, they could cover our
withdrawal covering move.
Obviously the assault party
required strengthening,
so I decided to take a total
patrol strength of six men.
One Bren with seven magazines and three
arms with statins were five magazines
and four 36 grenades each
plus a pair of wire cutters.
I carried my colt four
grenades and an umbrella.
My umbrella had been a source of amusement
to the platoons since I had found it
on the roadside and moocs apart from
keeping me dry in or out of a slit trench.
It was useful when prodding for mines
and brought some fun and color to our
lives.
Jim Kingston and Doug proctor fought
otherwise maintaining a disapproving
silence, which I failed to notice,
so now they're out on patrol.
Moving down the bank to the right,
we crawled forward in the mud and wet
grass until we were almost past the
orchard from which came the
sound of digging and voices.
Suddenly a challenge came from our front,
followed by a shower of stick grenades
thrown from a trench just inside the
orchard on our left.
One of the grenades
landed between my legs,
which were stretched out and spread apart.
As I lay flat on the river bank.
There was no flash. It's explosion
seemed muffled and more importantly,
owing to the soft mud I received,
not a scratch.
The game was up.
Now the concentrated fire of the
three stands poured into the German,
into the surprise.
Germans putting away my pistol,
I threw three 36 grenades in
quick succession into the orchard,
hurriedly reaching for my umbrella,
which alluded me.
And then ignominiously
ignominiously we beat a retreat.
So
okay,
he gets our gray throw at them. And I
actually had this happen to you bruiser.
Some guys were out on a patrol.
They were an open field.
They had cover from one side because
they had preplanned how they're going
across this field and
while they're out there,
they got hit with machine
gun fire and then mortars.
And they got mortars date on them.
And luckily because it was,
they weren't in like a muddy field,
like almost rice patty scenario.
The mortars, when they hit,
they went into the mud and so
they exploded, but there was no,
all the disruption was all absorbed
by the mud. That's lucky day for tea.
You bruiser right there.
Boys were little little fired up
when they came back from that one.
Now they get back into
a defensive perimeter.
I remember nights and defensive positions
like grosbeak stretched out in a slit
trench trying to get an hour sleep before
going round the platoon positions to
check that everything and
everyone was all right.
One felt and was dirty and in the small
hours of the morning with boot laces
cutting into swollen feet of foul
tasting mouth and an aching stomach,
life had little to commend it.
The dirt and discomfort worried
me more than the danger danger.
For some reason that I've
never understood exhilarates,
but despite every effort to keep clean,
it did not always prove possible
and that was unbearable.
Never once since I never once since have
I not been grateful to sink into a hot
bath or slide into a
bed with clean sheets.
We went to extraordinary lengths to
keep the dirt at bay. Once in Normandy,
I washed and shaved in the rain
water in the deep ruts made by carts.
Afterwards I discovered
that 400 yards away,
the opposition had been
overlooking my absolutions
a decent lot, who obviously
approved of my personal hygiene.
So if they didn't kill him, Hey,
this guy's just trying to be clean.
Let's let him continue back to
the book. During the campaign,
18 platoon carried out
three types of patrols,
reconnaissance standing and fighting.
The first two in variably useful because
they provided information if only
negative fighting patrols of which I led.
Many were different and
contemptuous proposition.
Unlike the German and American armies.
We had a vigorous policy regarding
fighting patrols, particularly at night,
and when things were static
on both sides on the defense.
The thinking behind this policy seemed
to me at times to be superficial and
probably leftover from the
Great War World War One.
If when detailed for a fighting patrol
young officer's queried the wisdom of its
given object, there was always the
standard reply. I quite agree with you,
but it all helps to
dominate no man's land.
There is undoubtedly a certain
validity of this argument,
but was it worth the consequent loss
of good young officers and CEO's?
I doubt it.
Shortly after the war,
I was able to briefly voice my
reservations to my illustrious army group
commander. That's Montgomery. By the way,
after giving me my Mc that's
military cross ribbon,
he stepped back and said,
crisply patrolling is bloody,
isn't it?
When I stammered,
that it seemed a bit hard that it was
always the same people chosen for patrols.
He replied with a twinkle in his eye.
One day you'll command a battalion
and you'll understand the problem
for 20 year olds.
Sub Alternate Exchange like this
with a field marshal was heady stuff,
but Monty's mischievous humor and utter
lack of compacity coupled with this
single minded professionalism,
professionalism extended his personal
influence to the most junior soldier in
21st army group.
We felt we knew him and that
he knew us often he did.
So
that's a great little interaction.
You know,
he says patrolling is bloody
work isn't it? And and Sydney,
Jerry says,
yeah and the thing is it seems like it's
always the same tunes that get made to
do the patrolling and he says one day
when you're in charge of Italian you'll
understand why that is and the reason
why that is cause you've got the good guy
and that's the guy
you're going to send out.
You're going to rely on the
people that get it done.
Well this is an interesting,
we've got another patrol that they're
getting ready to have to go out on and the
patrol was to pro between the
roads and advance if possible.
As far as the forest beyond this,
it's purpose was indeed vague.
Douglas called me and another platoon
commander to company HQ and explained it
to us. He then suggested we
should toss a coin for it.
An embarrassing situation arose. I thought
that the winner would lead the patrol.
The other officer had
dissipated that the loser would.
I lost the toss and got the job. So,
so imagine that you and me are saying,
all right, there's a dangerous
patrol we're going to have to do.
Let's flip for it.
I'm thinking heads.
If I win,
I get to do the patrol.
You're thinking in your view when
you don't have to do the patrol?
Uh, not everyone was quite as
fired up, I guess Sydney Jerry was
and they,
they wrap up a relatively
kind of uneventful patrol,
relatively uneventful patrol,
and he returns and they're having a
cup of tea and some biscuits. Sure.
In true British form,
back to the book,
it was then that I suddenly realized
that I'd been commanding 18 platoon for
months to be precise.
Three months and two days before I
joined the battalion in mid July,
I had been worn, worn that my life
expectancy would be about three weeks.
It seems strange to me now,
but at no time did I anticipate
being either wounded or killed.
I was just too busy for thoughts like
these and I become totally absorbed in my
grim responsibilities.
In July,
I had been written by doubt
about my ability in my innocence.
I'd expected success in battle to be
the prerogative of a victor low Durham,
which is like the champion.
I now had no such doubts or illusions.
Furthermore,
I discovered just how much soldiers
resent and fear a young officer who sees
battle as a means to win his spurs
possibly at the cost of their lives.
So when you grow in and you're Mr
beating your chest and you are who you're
going to prove yourself to the world.
Yeah,
don't be that guy cause you're going to
write checks with my life and we don't
like that.
My duty had become clear to me it
was to command 18 platoon with quiet
confidence providing
I made them only once.
My mistakes would be forgiven
if my soldiers were to go,
we're going to place their very
lives in my hands. They in return,
we're criers of me,
a serious attitude to my profession.
If I could achieve this with a
light touch so much the better.
That's an interesting comment.
So you know,
he's saying look what they require.
Is that going to be serious?
I'm got to be as serious as possible.
And the,
it's like you ever heard the term
minimum force required? Yeah. You read,
you probably use that as a
bouncer, right? Yeah. Hey,
you got to use the minimum force required.
So what he's saying is that as a
leader, the lighter touch, the better,
the lightest touch you can use to lead is
better. That's a pretty cool statement.
That's a good thing to think about.
How can you lead with minimum force
every time you go you use more than you,
then you need your,
you're overexerting right.
And who knows what kind of,
you know you're taken away initiative.
You might be stamping out morale.
So lead with that minimum touch.
I like that.
So at this point they're in a,
they're in a position and
there's three of these.
Mark three 75 millimeter
self propelled gone.
So they kind of look like tanks.
They got big tracks, they're Germans,
they're German, and their
end, they're sitting out in
front of them, they're in a,
they're in a static position.
The company's in a static position.
And there's these, these tanks
sitting there, three of them.
And Douglas looks at him and
he's thinking to himself, hey,
I don't know what those, they
look like, they're functioning,
they don't look damaged. And
so Douglas is saying, okay,
well we need to find out what's going on.
Even if there's no one,
even if there's no one in them right now.
Or it could be a place where they,
you snipers later.
Hmm.
So someone's got to go check them out.
So Sydney, Jerry, the
guy, he goes out alone,
Kinda sneaks out there.
He does stuff alone a little bit more
often than it actually does stuff alone.
There's another story I didn't mention,
but at one point there he hears noise.
Look,
one of the guys reports it's
nighttime and they hear,
they hear noise in this field.
They think there's an enemy
out there and he's white wall.
There's one way to find out.
So he,
I think he does grab another guy in this
occasion but it goes out and he's going
through this field and it's
like a cornfield or something
and he can't see any,
he's horrified and he can,
he's trying to think of a reason to quit.
He's like, I just want to go back.
This isn't smart. And as he's,
as this is taking place in,
his fear is climaxing all
of a sudden he hears a
bunch of cows and it feel good around.
So he's doing another solo operation here,
trying to find out what these tank
like assault guns are doing out there.
Back to the book, climbing up above the
tracks. I put my head into the Cupola,
which was open,
a familiar and terrible stench.
Hit me inside was a Sharnell
house six inches away,
a set of bare teeth set in unrecognizable
black and incinerated lump grinned at
me
beside it.
A chart and bony arm reached up in agony,
spread on the floor like a pool of tar
lay. The melted remains of the driver.
I had entered Dante's inferno.
Yeah,
my head real and with my mouth,
nose and lungs filled with the stench
of death. I fell back to the ground,
although on marked by
fire on all on our side,
all three assault guns had brewed up
and were black and on their sides which
faced the enemy.
Okay
with no stomach to look further.
I ran back to the company for
getting to look for American minds.
Okay.
Never again did I look into a
knocked out tank or self propelled.
Guns are reported a Douglas that nobody
in their right mind would use them for
an observation post or for any purpose.
Later that day he asks,
that's Douglas Douglas asked the commander
of a Sherman tank to fire some armor
piercing shells into each of them
positioning his tank hold down.
Besides 16 platoons positions which
were two are left the tank commanders to
take greater first selected the assault
gun I had visited his first shell hit.
It's slightly above the tracks
like the hammer, a Vulcan,
a red glow blossomed on the armor plate
around the point of entry and slowly
faded.
It was followed by a second and third
shell until a mirage of heat appeared
above it and for a second time the
funeral pyre blazed with an incandescent
ferocity.
The Sherman gunner then turned his
attention to the next assault gun,
which despite being penetrated by
about six armor piercing rounds,
failed to brew up his
first shot at the third,
caused a massive internal designation,
no doubt due to ammunition stacked
within a volcano erupted from its cappola
sending a dense cloud of black smoke,
smoke and red sparks into the air.
A truly Wagnerian and for the
warriors and tuned within,
but it revolted me
for the rest of the day.
I booted this communicated itself to
my NCS and soldiers who stole mystified
glances at my grief for an unknown enemy.
During the afternoon,
I wandered across the road to a loan house
were Dennis Clark had his observation
post. I was looking for solace
from a wise and good friend.
The post was filled with Gunnar officers.
There must have been a dozen of them
setting up their equipment in preparation
for an attack by two one four brigade.
This activity precluded any solace for me,
immature and undisciplined.
My imagination ran riot.
What would they like?
These men who's already incinerated
remains had been blasted into oblivion by
the 75 millimeter shells of
our friend in the Sherman.
My attitude door was ambivalent.
Undoubtedly I was parked pacifist,
but despite an abysmal record in
mathematics and particularly in geometry,
I was moderately logical for my age.
This clearly ruled out total
dedication to pacifism.
I had previously discussed the concept
of conscientious objection with clergy of
all denominations,
but none of them could give me
constructive answers to my questions.
The privations and suffering
of 18 platoon hurt me
an saw Baltar
and he's faced with a conflict
which cannot be resolved.
One gets emotionally involved
with those under one's command.
Without this bond,
few men will respond and
consequently little can be achieved.
However,
to win battles,
decisions have to be taken and orders
given which at times may seem to be a
betrayal of this trust.
Before battle,
the commander must exude
confidence and enthusiasm.
Whatever fears his
private thoughts may hold.
Just how thin aligned divides
this from deliberate deception.
I call it the commander's dilemma,
a pretentious phrase,
but there is nothing to be done about it.
In Nicholas Montserrat's book,
the Cruel Sea Poor Commander Eric
Hansen makes the point with poignancy.
Yeah,
it's the war,
the whole bloody war.
We've just got to do these things
and say our prayers. At the end
there was another side
possibly caused by adrenaline,
danger,
attracted and excited me.
I felt elated and until
the battle was over,
I was impervious to exhaustion.
Commanding a platoon,
embattled demands not only a clear mind,
but also considerable emotional force.
I suspect it is the same transmitted
force that exists between a conductor and
orchestra.
40 years later,
the dilemma of my ambivalence
is still unresolved.
I find the suffering inflicted by war,
unacceptable,
particularly amongst women,
children and animals.
Thank God I was spared the horrific sites.
It filets on some days I am a pacifist
and yet I'm still attracted by the sounds
of guns and but for an extraordinarily
happy marriage would have
found it difficult to resist
the lure of soldiering.
So what he calls
the commanders dilemma,
and this what I call the
dichotomy of leadership.
And that one is the premier of the mall.
And that is as a leader,
as a combat leader,
there you are going love your man
and care about them more than
anything else in the world.
And with that,
okay,
you are going to make
decisions and make plans
where you are sending those men into a
situation to where they can be wounded or
killed.
And that's it.
And that is the ultimate
dichotomy of leadership.
That is the hardest one to balance
back to the book,
a new officer arrived named Humphreys.
He used to play cricket for worst usher.
He came on the same day that sergeant
Oxland received a well earned commission
in the field.
Okay?
Douglass told them about sergeant Oxland
and with great consideration he went to
17 platoons position to
offer as congratulations.
Okay.
While they talked just one salvo
of one oh five straddled them,
one shell fell into second lieutenant
Auckland's slit trench and both were
killed instantly.
Like me,
Ken Oxen has survived five months,
Humphrey survived,
not a full day.
Is there a mathematical formula by
which survival can be calculated?
Who are the survivors and
can they be recognized
over the past 40 years?
I've often pondered this,
but still offer no real answer.
Okay.
I suspect, however, that is
something to do with attitude.
The attitude seems to me to be a
parameter which restricts not only our
relationships,
but also our creative effort.
Further comment is unwise.
Humphreys,
one could argue had little time to develop
an attitude to our kind of existence.
Undoubtedly a self fulfilling circle
develops newcomers inexperienced in the
perils of the battlefield,
suffered the highest casualties,
knowledge of what can and what cannot be.
Wrist postpones the fatal
recognizing for the soldier.
Yeah,
for the commander.
However,
Jr battlefield experience
will not only protect himself,
but also all those under his command.
Okay.
And that's the,
that's why training is so important.
So important. And that's why when I got
done with, you know, deployment to Ramadi,
it's why went to training?
Because I knew that right there
and I was thinking,
you know,
I didn't know how long the water was
going to ask him when we left Ramadi.
Ramadi was still horrible.
Okay.
And when the task unit
came in, relieved us, man,
they were getting after it and I didn't
know how long that was gonna last.
I mean, it ended up not lasting that much
longer, that kind of intense fighting,
but it was impossible
to tell at that time.
We were just barely seeing stuff start
to get started to get better at the end
of our deployment, just barely starting
to see the first indications of that
back to the book.
Okay.
The fifth Duke of Cornwall is Light
Infantry at attempted to attack Hoven
village through these ghastly woods
and had taken heavy casualties there.
Rain soaked bodies littered the paths
and clearings while carrying out a
reconnaissance. I came across one
of their sections lying across,
lying along a small path facing the enemy.
Okay.
At first,
I fought them alive until I saw that
the studs on their boots were rusty and
their webbing equipment
was bleached with rain.
Their battle dress was starched with mud
and their hands and faces were green.
German booby traps were on
or near many of the tracks,
and I was told by the company commander
of the fourth wheelchairs from whom we
took over the position that some of
the bodies were also booby trapped.
Don't try to bury them.
He said
I was temporarily commanding the company
because Douglas had been given a well
deserved leave and Brussels,
although militarily,
comparatively uneventful,
Hoven has a special place in my memories.
It was without a doubt my most,
the most grisly and horrifying
position that we ever hold held.
But more importantly,
it was the place of private
Charles Ravens triumph.
Raven had fought in all our battles
since hill one 12 which to him was a yard
stick of horror.
All subsequent experience was
compared with that. His first battle,
he was no soldier.
I doubt if he influenced greatly any of
the skirmishes and counters or battles
in which he took part.
Sometimes he was frightened and he was
so out of place on the battlefield that I
often wondered how he
became an infantry soldier
before the war.
He had been a clerk in north London.
I'm sure he was a conscientious and loyal
employee and a considerate and loving
husband for unlike most of us.
He was married.
Yeah.
Raven had hidden depths and could be
inspired once a Normandy during a nasty
little platoon attack up a sunken lane.
18 platoon was held up by the inevitable
unlocated spanned dose straining my
eyes through binoculars.
I was trying vainly to locate these guns
when I was handed a steaming mug of tea.
Yeah,
he should've been observing to his
front, but judging the moment, right,
he had brewed a mess tin of tea on
a solid fuel stove by any standards.
This wasn't inspired act.
He was considerate with our
reinforcements. Pale on sure men,
some of whom until recently it served
in the royal artillery and had been
transferred to infantry regiments to
replace the appalling losses incurred in
the Norman depot cottage.
Beside them,
raven looked bronzed and weather beaten.
A hardened campaigner complete with
a German Luger pistol to prove it.
Some of the platoon regaled
the reinforcements with
horrible tales from Normandy
and elsed as little
more than a school boy.
I found these stories
and music raven did not.
Fear for him was horribly real
and never to be joked about.
He developed a paternal attitude
toward the newer and younger soldiers,
a relationship devoid of patronage,
but essentially one of
kindly understanding.
He spoke to me about it when the,
I thanked him for his help.
I admit I'm dead windy sir.
His extraordinary honesty with himself
from the rest of the platoon forbade him
to attempt to hide the fact raven
and overtaxed as nervous and physical
resources long before we
arrived in Hoven woods.
Yeah.
After two days in the position,
he came to me late one evening and
asked my permission to report sick the
following morning.
I suppose I should and
physically have refused,
but something made me hesitate and avoid
dealing directly with the situation.
I said simply, all right, raven,
but do come see me before you leave.
He didn't come.
The matter was never again mentioned.
I can only surmise the struggle which
raged in his mind all that night while he
crouched in his water log,
slit trench,
peering into the sinister
darkness of the wood.
I do know,
however,
that in Hoven would a considerable moral
triumph over stark horror was achieved
by a good man,
unequipped equipped for nature
on a cooked by nature for war
in my view,
the bravest of the brave.
So that guy rave and had been through
all this stuff and just barely held the
line. And finally he was going to break.
Finally he was going to break and he,
and he comes to city Jerry and says,
Hey, I'm, I'm good to go sick tomorrow,
Cindy. Jerry says, okay, come and see
me before you go. He doesn't come back.
It doesn't come back to him,
doesn't go sick.
Okay,
back to the book.
Infantry warfare is wretched business.
It makes physical and emotional demands
on participants that run contrary to all
human instinct.
The strong minority must
quietly help the weak majority.
To me,
that is the essence of good teamwork.
And that jewel in the
crown of the British army,
the regimental system is the strong
foundation upon which we all knowingly or
unknowingly relied.
So there's gonna be some people
that deal with it better than others
and you've got to help them.
Here's the situation.
They set up early warning flares,
so we'll trip wires in case due to to
notify them if the enemy's moving down one
of their flanks.
And here we go back to the book.
After about 10 minutes had passed,
we heard the popping of mortars behind
Hoven village and a concentration of
bombs fell in the fields where we had
laid the flares suddenly are left flank,
was vividly illuminated as
flare after flare ignited.
Knowing little about these flares, we had
laid them with the trip wires to talk.
How do we allow to degree of slack? The
flares would not have ignited my fault.
I should have known,
had to throw a little extreme
ownership from Sydney,
Jerry and therefore y'all sure.
Now he's talking about the attitudes
of the soldiers and how soldiers,
you know,
there was a claim,
he read an article years after the
war that said that people, you know,
people became brutal from the,
from the war.
And here's what he says back to the book
does a war brutalize one can only speak
from personal experience,
but I think not.
Certainly no soldier of
mine was made brutal.
Rather the opposite war developed an 18
platoon consideration for comrades and
humanity towards civilians
and prisoners of war.
I was proud of my soldiers then and
this sentiment has increased with the
passing of years.
I would not suggest that the naturally
brutal might not find in Warren outlet
for their brutality.
However,
that ward is not brutalize
the type of decent men,
the type of decent and fair minded young
English men whom I had the very great
honor to command.
We were not an aggressive
generation of fact,
which may explain my failure to understand
some present day attitudes and the
armed services, particularly in the
Royal Marines and the parachute regimen.
Okay.
Possibly a degree of personal aggression
is appropriate and troops are come who
are committed to battle for comparatively
short periods like the marines and the
Paris when the success of an operation
depends on ultra rapid action.
However, in my experience,
troops lose personal aggression.
After about two months in battle,
after three months,
they acquire a mature compassion,
which in no way detracts from
their authentic of capability.
They simply know a lot more about war.
Okay.
I would suggest that personal aggression
should not be confused with authentic
of spirit based on professional
competence and experience.
Interesting.
Take that aggression that you can maintain
if you,
it's not going to last forever and,
and then you're going to have to
fall back on duty and,
and that mature compassion,
which isn't taken away from
their offensive capability.
Interesting.
Back to the book on the 11th of January,
we returned to the south. Fine. Yeah.
Just to go back to that one piece
right there. Dichotomy, leadership.
There's a dichotomy and everything and uh,
you know,
obviously I'm a big proponent of being
aggressive and I also always talk about
the fact that there is such a
thing as being too aggressive.
You're running to your
death. No, not a good idea.
Not a good idea.
And there's probably a good chance that
when he talks about people after two
months of combat, everyone
starts to develop a different
type of attitude. Also,
the people that were ultra
aggressive didn't make it like the,
like the leader that he talked about that
was strutting around the guy was ultra
aggressive, didn't care about
anything, and he's dead. Yeah,
so there's a balance you got to have.
That's the dichotomy of leadership.
That's why the dichotomy of leadership is
so important and so hard to understand.
Back to the book, on the day after the
battalion was relieved in Hoeven Woods,
someone I suspect,
I suspect it was the adjutant,
Tim Watson decided that I should
enjoy 48 hours on leave in Antwerp.
I was overjoyed.
The large hotel,
although faded, we're still plush and
filled with officers, including women,
ATS officers from the various base unit
stationed in the city dressed as I left
the battlefield.
I was both disheveled and soiled,
surrounded by the residents,
many of whom were in service dress.
I could not have felt
more isolated and lonely.
So he's getting some leave time, but he's
showing up off the battlefield. Grimy.
My first visit was to a magnificent white
marble gentleman's hairdressing salon
in the basement of a hotel.
Okay?
Without a word.
The Barbara washed and rinsed my hair
twice before touching it with his precious
scissors and clippers.
I remember the feeling of
wellbeing as climbing the stairs.
I returned to my room
next,
I took three very hot baths,
one after the other to
rid myself of grime,
both physical and emotional.
I think I must have slept for
14 hours before I rose shaved,
took another bath and
decided to explore the city.
Uh, rather creased battle
dress was my best suit.
And in this I descended the
main staircase into the lounge,
which was filled with
the resident officers,
all of whom seem to be
annoyingly self assured.
I met a barrier.
Okay.
I had walked out of a world that I knew
into one where I was desperately unsure
of myself
away from the battlefield.
This world,
I had no place for me.
I did not go out to lunch,
go to nightclubs,
or meet the girls who were everywhere
seem to be canvassing for these
establishments.
I had wandered too far into dark and
smokey battlefields across the sticks to
find solace or comfort in the bright
lights behind the blackout curtains of
Antwerp.
I longed to return to the
battalion and to 18 platoon,
which without my knowing it
okay
had become my home
with a light heart,
a clean body,
flesh,
freshly laundered clothes and
refreshed by hours of unbroken sleep.
I gladly climbed into the three ton
truck that took me there years later.
I found the same problem
after I left the army.
Antwerp had been a small taste of the
real world and as anyone who has served
with good soldiers on grim battlefields,
we'll confirm afterwards.
Real life never seems real again.
Later.
There was no 18 platoon to slink back to.
Okay.
And without a
will loving wife,
it would have proved in tolerable.
Well, that's the feeling that that we get.
Yeah.
When you get done doing that job.
Okay.
And real life. Never seen. He
was real again in comparison.
I know the vets that are
listening to understand that part.
Back to the book on 11 January,
we returned to the south of Holland.
This time to gang gang lit snow lay on
deeply frozen ground and life for the
intro and life for the infantry. Manning
their slit trenches became unbearable
again. The Battalion Front was
extensive. D Company was in reserve,
closed close to battalion
headquarters on the edge of town.
Fortunately gang out was on a reverse
slope which allowed us to move freely
during daylight hours.
The cold was penetrating.
The oil in our automatic weapons froze
and until antifreeze lubricants were
issued,
our brands were useless.
Holding a wide front with large gaps
between our company positions necessitated
putting out many standing patrols,
particularly at night.
The privation suffered
by these small patrols.
Usually a corporal and three or four
men were harder than the rest of us.
Some had hallucinations and if you
were exact a evacuated suffering from
exposure,
keeping fit,
warm and clean became a great effort.
Conversation dried up.
The platoon became quiet but never morose.
At one stage.
I decided they needed cheering up and I
wandered around the section post ready
to chat with all of them.
It was quite unnecessary.
I had wrongly judged their mood.
They just wanted to be left alone.
Now there's a,
again by the book and read the book.
There's a chaotic bottle battle at a
pace place called Cleve and after the
battle of cleave,
he kind of debriefs here back to the book.
What instructors at the school of infantry
would think about the fighting Cleve.
I shutter to think it resembled
no other battle. In my experience.
I have little control and it developed
into a section commanders battle.
Looking back over the years, it seems
military leave totally unprofessional,
are real wild west shootout.
Tactically,
the Germans had every advantage.
We were strung out in a long column,
a mid shattered buildings and piles
of rebels with the groups of parachute
troops attacking both sides.
They could snipe at us
and engage with our,
with their spanned owls
from dozens of physicians,
totally hidden by piles of rubble.
They had the opportunity to concentrate
their counter attacks on the narrowest
of fronts but failed to do to do so,
so they failed to focus their efforts.
I can only assume that we had
the psychological advantage,
the circumstances being so chaotic and
disorganized, perhaps being Germans,
they cannot overcome their instinct
for organization and tidiness.
In the end,
they departed possibly and discussed
leaving us undisputed victors
on another attack.
The Germans at this point are
retreating and they can see that they're
retreating.
Fearing that the retreating parachute
troops would make a stand on the edge of
the wood.
I increased the rate of advance joining
Lance Corporal Porteous in the forward
section running across the level crossing,
I suddenly found myself face to face with
a German platoon complete with the MG
34 fortunately,
the gun was mounted on a tripod which
was unusual and could not be traversed in
our direction from a drainage channel.
On the left of the road,
a parachute has leaped up.
Swathed and Camouflage Vale pointing
is Schweizer at me from about 10 yards
range. He fired a whole
magazine of about 30 rounds.
It was like watching a
slow running silent movie.
I didn't hear the chatter
of the [inaudible],
but I do remember seeing this
stream of empty cartridges.
Cartridge cases fly
from the German machine.
Gun Miracles do indeed happen.
One nine millimeter bullet
went through my baret,
missing my head literally
by a hair's width.
Another went under the
Epilep of my jacket,
penetrating the webbing or cross brace.
The webbing cross brace of my equipment
in grazing. My right shoulder,
a third bullet ricocheted off the
surface of the road and disintegrated the
jacket. Finally, lodging in
the palm of my right hand.
Then came the anticlimax.
The German looked at me in amazement
through way as sir and I with a shrug of
the shoulders.
He surrendered.
My natural elation was
short lived behind me.
Lay Lance corporal Porteous
shot through the heart.
Some of the German platoon ran away across
the open fields to our left and were
cut down by rapid fire.
Bren gun by Sergeant Kingston Section,
which now wind the railway
track to the left of the road.
The remainder of the enemy came towards
us over the level crossing with their
hands raised.
We took 57 prisoners.
Yeah.
Now they're moving along and they are
clearing some cottages and they get to
this one cottage filled
with rough wooden bunks.
It it obviously served
as an air raid shelter.
The house having been
found clear of enemy.
Jack Lee was off his guard as he descended
the steps suddenly from under a pile
of blankets lept the
fanatical German paratrooper.
The only fanatical German paratrooper
we encountered the entire battle.
A large man, he sees Jack around the
throat in an attempt to strangle him.
Private fluid rose to
the challenge in a bound.
He was down the steps and with a mighty
lunge transfixed the German on his band
net,
a brave lad.
He undoubtedly saved Lance Corporal Lee's
life just eight days before losing his
own.
The German was indeed unlucky as it
was the only occasion throughout the
campaign on which 18 paltunes
bayonets were bloodied.
We usually use them to open food cans,
having checked the platoon positions
and arcs of fire for the brands.
Exhaustion hit me.
Yeah.
I fell into a deep sleep during
the evening. A senior officer,
I understand it was either to
brigade or divisional commander,
came out to my company position
when he asked to speak to me.
Sergeant Kingston refuse
to have me wakened.
I'm sure that Jim was the
most diplomatic about it,
but it says much for our visitors,
humanity that he let it go by
another attack.
A and c companies were unleashed
and passing be company,
secure their objectives
against some opposition.
There was now our turn d company advanced
across the flat open fields down the
left hand side
of the main road into Zam 10 it's the
name of the city or village casualties
from the preceding companies in the
opposition lay all around about 300 yards
short of the town were
extremely accurately engaged
by a battery of one oh five
s some of their shells
exploded on the hard surface.
The road earsplitting detonations and
frightening fragmentation pieces of shell
casing hummed in wind around us.
One twirling piece in bedded itself with
a thud into the trunk of a tree a few
inches from my right ear was the only
time in the whole campaign when I
regretted throwing away my steel helmet.
I think it was the accuracy
and the intense noise of
the showing that caused it.
One of 18 platoons,
lance corporals,
a big man who had served honorably
since market garden went to pieces.
There was a pathetic sight
and to everyone's credit,
he was removed from the battle.
He had passed his limit and
nothing more can be said,
so you don't know. These guys are brave
at one moment and then a week, a month,
two months, four months.
They can't do it anymore.
Okay?
They get across the Rhine.
Now they're fully in Germany.
There's a little bit of a lull
in the fighting back to the book.
Early one morning while we were waiting
for our supporting armor to arrive,
our pod Dre,
John Williams drove a receipt us after
wandering around the platoon for a chat.
He suggested he suggested that
we should go for a short stroll.
I had now been commanding 18 platoon
for over eight months and I suspect that
our adjutant Tim Watson,
a kindly soul,
had asked him to find
out what shape I was in.
We had not gone far into the next
field when he came across some grizzly
remnants.
One of our artillery shells must have
exploded right at the feet of a German
soldier who had been digging.
A slit.
Trench is splintered and twisted.
Spade lay beside laid by the side of
that half dug trench beside which was a
small shell hole.
He had been disintegrated into
small pieces of flesh and bone,
which lay scattered all over the field.
Had I been on my own,
I would no doubt have shuttered and
quickly departed from this horror
draped over a wire fence nearby.
Lay a parachute,
which are extraordinarily brave.
Padre spread out as a shroud
on the cold and damp grass.
Then stooping.
He walked around the field,
a lonely figure reverently picking
up every piece of that poor soldier.
To my shame,
I stood and watched him.
I lack the courage to help
somewhere beneath those flat damp
fields just north of the Ryan.
That pallette it. Pathetic
Bundle. Must still lie.
Now they're an attack again,
but it seems like things are going
their way and we're going, he's,
he's kind of giving a brief to his,
to his runner.
When all of a sudden he hears yelling
back to the books or they're charging us.
Sure enough,
from about 150 yards ahead of wealth
spread outline of about 20 Germans were
putting in a bayonet charge.
Brave lads,
they didn't stand a chance.
Okay.
I gave no orders except ceasefire,
not one God within 75 yards of us,
a few minutes later,
a possession of Germans with stretchers
and a huge red flag emerged from the
village behind.
Yeah.
When they were close to their casualties,
they hesitated.
So I stood up and waved them on,
all wore on arms stretcher bearers,
and they moved across our front
collecting their dead and wounded
when they had finished their
task of mercy. One of them,
I think he must have been a German
medical officer turned and saluted in our
direction.
Okay.
I returned the salute
and with that gesture,
the tiny battle of Cinderella ended.
Yeah.
In Bremen, little over a month
later, one of our stretcher bearers,
Lance Corporal Jay Stevens,
was killed by a German grenade as he
went to tend to wounded German soldier.
18 platoon remembering syndrome were
justifiably outraged by such on soldierly
behavior.
Okay.
There is a mathematical formula.
Aggression increases.
The further one goes behind the lines.
Opposing infantry with few exceptions
like the SS are joined by a natural bond
of mutual compassion,
which few but the aristocracy of
the battlefield can understand
the public influence,
no doubt by writers with literally no
experience of battle have strange and
sometimes silly ideas about
what makes a good soldier.
Ill informed television programs
have added to this misunderstanding.
Few professions can be have
been so misleadingly caricature.
Okay.
I had,
I been asked at the time before August,
1944 to list the personal characteristics
which go to make a good infantry
soldier. My reply would indeed have
been wider than mark wide of the mark.
Like most I no doubt would have suggested
only masculine ones like aggression,
physical stamina. A hunting instinct
instinct and competitive nature.
Okay,
how wrong I would have been,
I would now suggest the following,
firstly,
sufferance
without which one could not survive.
So he's listing what he thinks the most
important characteristics for for an
infantry soldier are. The first one
is sufferance, the ability to suffer.
Secondly,
a quiet mind which enables a soldier to
live in harmony with his fellows through
all sorts of difficulties and
sometimes under dreadful conditions.
As in a closed monastic existence,
there is simply no
room for the assertive or acrimonious.
Thirdly, below, no less important.
A sense of the ridiculous which helps
us soldiers surmount the unacceptable
add to these are reasonable standard
of physical fitness and a dedicated
professional competence.
And you have a soldier for all seasons.
None of the soldiers are
ntls who made 18 platoon.
What it was resembled the
characters portrayed in most
books and films about war.
All quiet,
sensible on assuming and
some by any standard.
We're heroes.
If I now had to select a team for a
dangerous mission and my choice was
restricted to stars of
the sports field or poets,
I would own hesitatingly
recruit from the ladder.
Very interesting.
And I mean,
obviously you have to put this in
the context of, of his time, but
okay.
There's no doubt that,
I mean,
you get a sports star,
especially these days,
those guys that are getting paid 2030
$40 million a year to play a game,
they're, they're probably not going to
be the best at suffering in a trench.
Okay.
Interesting. And I, and I think
the key point of that is what is,
going back to what he talks about earlier,
is he someone that can think, hmm.
Someone that can think
someone that is not trapped
in, in thinking the same
thoughts as everyone else,
which certainly an artist or a poet has
to be outside the box of normal fought.
Otherwise they become, they
don't become that. Right.
Okay.
In this situation.
His platoon is kind of pin down
and there's an air raid shelter,
which has someone in it is firing
these things called a panzer Faust,
which is like a,
it's kind of like a bazooka or like an
RPG looking thing and he sees where it's
coming from and he sees that
it's this shelter. Yeah,
but he doesn't know who's in the shelter.
Here we go back to the COO.
Who else was in the shelter?
Women and children's sheltering more
enemy soldiers with more pounds or Faust
and spanned o's.
We were in a vulnerable situation and
it was no good pushing forward and
ignoring the Metis lurking
inside that shelter. I could have
sent two or three men to clear it.
However,
experience it taught me that when clearing
sellers that the first man sent in is
invariably killed.
Okay.
Instead, concentrated fire was poured
into the entrance, included get pee out,
bomb.
Okay.
Around us.
The battle still raged and no opportunity
arose for Medians for me to inspect
the consequences of an awful decision.
Nevertheless,
my duty was to win battles and not to
gamble with the lives of my soldiers by
fussing over too sensitive a conscience.
So there you go.
There's a dichotomy for you.
If the one hand he's looking at the
shelter thinking there might be women and
kids in there,
but at this moment in time he doesn't
have time to find out and doesn't have
time to,
to take the most cautious route.
So they hammer it with machine gun
fire and some some anti tank rounds.
He never even goes to look.
Hmm. But he knows that he can't,
his duty is to win battles and he can't
dilly dally because he has a sensitive
conscious doesn't work.
Back to the book.
Bremerhaven was our final objective.
Yeah.
It was 5th of May,
1945 19 days before my 21st birthday.
Thinking about what you were doing,
you were twins.
That's why it's so interesting.
Ready to break out.
Okay.
We were concentrated at,
we'll stat about 20 miles north
of Bremen when the end came,
and by the end,
I mean the end of the war,
129 brigades order was
stand down and splice.
The main brace,
which is a military,
is actually a navy term splice.
The main brace me,
it's like drinking light is lit.
You can drink the war's over.
I had just given orders for our small
part in the Brigades move forward against
15 panzer division,
one of the famous Africa core formations.
Yeah.
In 1983 Jim Kingston gave
me his copy of those orders,
which he had kept all those years
reaction to the end of the war,
like aggression increased
further behind the lines.
One went,
okay.
The natural aristocracy
of the battlefield,
the infantry having fired a photo,
joy,
a very lights curled up and slept.
We had learned too much to
indulge in shallow demonstrations,
so everyone's all fireworks and getting
crazy. These guys are like, cool,
I'm going to sleep.
Yeah.
Okay.
Since July, we had come a long
way from the Normandy beach head.
Okay.
The battalion had lost 47 officers
and 1,260 and [inaudible] and private
soldiers killed or wounded
after July 31st,
1944 no member of 18
platoon was put on a charge.
No one went absent or deserted.
Yeah.
Of the original 36 NCRS and
soldiers who had landed in Normandy,
only corporal Cheesman remained,
or one man,
many came after them and lasted
a few days, weeks or months.
Phew.
I was able to thank adequately,
I doubt if any of them realized how
much I personally owed 18 platoon.
Okay.
When I joined them on 31st of July,
I was naive and Gosh,
due to a narrow upbringing except
for a passionate love of music,
my intellect and emotions
were unstimulated.
My achievement at school had been abysmal.
My mind was undisciplined and
confidence in myself. Nil.
This was rapidly swept away
probably within three weeks,
certainly before we crossed
the CN on the 28th of August,
discovering an ability to
command a group of men,
some frightened and but wilderness
produced a new found confidence,
particularly since I seem to be able to
achieve it quietly and without acrimony
or foss,
having to improvise tactics to overcome
the shortcomings of battle school
training also helped. It proved
to me that in some circumstances,
older and more experienced deny others
older and more experienced than I could
be wrong.
I suspect that as an only child,
I had been brought up in
too much off my elders.
Yeah,
a new world. It opened before me.
Forethought and planning were demanded.
Imagination and instinct too.
Was that apparently quiet
Normandy lane lethal,
the intense Spandau fire
and mortaring along a dyke.
Was it a prelude to an enemy's withdrawal?
Did the orchard in front
of the village hide 88
okay.
My judgment and these things had proved
equal to better than most of them the
most,
and it was the making of me.
It also brought a few problems.
I'm now only able to plan and run
things in my way. As a result,
I'm probably unemployable.
Okay.
However, I would never wish
to change places with the shy,
hesitant boy whom circumstances
put in command of 18 we'll tune
age 20 I was far too
young and inexperienced to
appreciate that an infantry
platoon was the finest command in the
army and that's the success or failure of
a so often lay solely in the
hands of a young officer.
Okay.
After careful reflection,
I doubt that at any time since the
war have I carried the burden of
responsibility that I bore
has a softball turn in battle.
Wait, an army core division or
brigade was committed to battle.
It was the battalion company and platoon
commanders who took over the mantle of
responsibility from the generals
from the generals and brigadiers.
Okay.
And close country forests
and street fighting.
The platoon commander became the linchpin.
Yeah.
Only the company at platoon commanders,
particularly the ladder,
we're able to have close
relationship with their soldiers,
which is a prerequisite for
having above average success
failure by one infantry company.
Correct. A divisional battle plan.
Okay.
Conversely gallant success,
like be company at Zahn 10
underwrote the battalion's victory.
Again,
I would emphasize the analog with the
bond of professional respect between a
great conductor and the members of a
symphony orchestra without which a truly
great performance is not possible.
Outstanding performances cannot be
arranged in a concert promoters office.
They're created by some magic by the
conductor and players and rehearsal and
performance.
Similarly,
while senior commanders appreciated
the strengths and weaknesses of their
battalions and brigades,
they could not extract a great performance
from the rifleman upon whom victory
dependent
only the company or platoon commanders
supported by their NC o's could ensure
that
42 years on,
I get considerable satisfaction from 18
platoon successes more so than I got at
the time.
So those were his thoughts in it.
And he's the wars now over
and
a few days after the war ended.
Um,
well go to the book after
cholera inoculations,
we were conducted into
the world of Frankenstein.
Yeah.
Nothing had prepared us for
what we now experienced,
not hill one 12,
not mount pin shown elsewhere or
Hoven could compete with this horror
before the incredulous eyes.
If 18 platoon spread over
acres of delightfully wooded
countryside was a factory
of death,
emaciated bodies resembling wax effigies
of an alien race from a strange and
distant planet
filled many pits.
The stench of death and the site of such
highly industrialized human degradation
left my soldiers speechless.
Private Macy d companies jeep
driver aptly summed it up.
There is now no doubt that
we have fought a just war.
That's after they saw the
concentration camps. Obviously
back to the book.
Within a month of the war ending 21st
army group was required to supply junior
officers for the 14th army in Burma.
Lippi the commanding officer decided
that I should be one of them.
And by then being intent on a military
career, I was not inclined to argue.
I would gain useful
experience of jungle warfare,
of which I knew nothing about.
So they're getting orders still a
war going on in the Pacific. Oh,
you wrapped up portion from Normandy
through Germany. Through their surrender.
Guess, well, we need, we need
people to go to fight in Asia.
We need people in Burma.
I was totally unprepared for the platoons,
for the emotions that were unleashed
immediately after I was deprived of 18
platoon,
has a jeep,
took me away from the battalion,
a ghastly desolation and Gulf to me,
I felt like a small boy on his way to
a grim and unknown boarding school.
The pleasures of commanding 18 platoon
in peace time or being denied me.
And
it's interesting. So he's gets
pulled away from his platoon and,
and he goes into talk about what
happened to the guys that survived,
that he knew. And I, I found this
part to be fascinating in the
how these people went back to normal
life. Back to the book, Jim Kingston
was demobilized in January,
1946 and two months later he returned
to his civilian post with the Bristol
Corporation,
Electricity Department,
retired in 1975 never
married Doug proctor,
return home to his wife and
baby son and Nottingham.
And March of 1946 found the
transition from army to civilian life,
painless. Returning to his
accounting post in the coal.
Oh, in Cheesman. During the first
few days of his demobilization,
his wife died miserable. And for Lauren,
he returned to his old
job in Covent garden.
And a few years later he met and
married Bella, who in his own words,
was a comfort and inspiration to him.
Charles Raven joined the London
transport as a bus conductor
later transferring to the clerical staff
and rose by hard work and study to be a
garage inspector.
Joe Thomas and George Harish went
into the building trade industry in
Bridgewater.
Surprisingly,
just incredibly normal paths after
this incredibly not normal life.
And,
and what happened to Sidney Jerry?
So here's what happened to
Sidney. Jerry, back to the book,
arriving in England on 9th of July,
1945 I reported to the Holding Battalion
of the Hampshire Regiment at Westgate
on C and was immediately
sent on 28 days leave
after a night out in London with
three friends, also Burma bound.
I telephoned my parents
and found them away
chopping them to Bognor Regis.
I caught a train from
Waterloo and went to see them
staying at the same hotel as my parents
were flight Lieutenant Jack weatherleys
widow.
Peggy and their three year old daughter
and we're staying at the same hotel as
his parents at once.
A bond of deep understanding and
affection developed between us.
In August,
an atom bomb was dropped and so at a
stroke my visit to Burma was rendered
pointless.
So two in my heart was a military career.
I soldiered on in Libya and Palestine
with the first battalion of my own regimen
for two more interesting years and
finally was demobilized in May of 1947
within a week of leaving the army,
I attended a job interview.
The managing director who saw me,
a pale and thin lipped man was a
business acquaintance of a relative.
He,
I'd meet coldly slowly and
precisely from his desk.
He lifted a ruler,
which he rudely pointed at my face.
I understand that you made a slight
name for yourself from the war.
Be that as it may people like you.
Jerry should remember that while you
have been gallivanting around the world,
most of my staff had remained
loyalty to come to the company.
If you can give me one valid reason
why should even consider you for any
position,
I should be interested to hear it.
I nearly hit him
now.
I wish that I had quickly
grabbing my hat and umbrella.
I rose and told him that if he
was the last man in the world,
I would rather starve than work for him.
With that I left my heart pounding
and a foul taste in my mouth.
I walked aimlessly through miles of
streets wishing that I was back on some
battlefield with real men.
Soldiers like 18 platoon
armistice day brings its problems.
Peg and I would like to go to church.
We used to go but found almost without
exception a lack of perception and
sensitivity amongst the clergy.
We suffered one armistice
day cert sermon devoted to
the cure rates theory that war
being a crime against humanity.
All Chivalry must there
for be hypocritical.
I wondered whether the German stretcher
bearers and they're wounded at Syndrom
would have agreed.
I took offense pag and I
have a lot to mourn. She,
Jack Weatherly and I,
18 platoons dead.
Perhaps it is expecting too much of
anyone to understand intense grief,
particularly that of a now aging platoon
commander who had to lead some of his
men to their deaths.
We now spend arm assist day quietly
at home
with our ghosts.
Memories abound during the night.
I made a habit of wandering around the
platoon positioned so that each of my
soldiers could talk to me.
I learned a lot.
They talked about their
families and their future hopes.
I hardly had to contribute to
those whispered conversations
that some times took
place in the dead of night or in the
cold gray light just before dawn.
I think it may have helped my
soldiers to have a confidant,
invaluable experience of human nature.
I now treasure the memory
weapons. Also left
memories, the monotonous,
repetitive bursts of the Brin,
the hysterical of the MG 42 for furious
rate of fire and the lethal chatter of
the stands and schmeissers all contribute,
all contributed to the cacophony of battle
tracer.
Bullets seared themselves into memory.
Fired from a distance.
Yeah,
the parrot,
the parrot.
Bola approached almost laser Lee until
suddenly like a swarm of fiery demons.
They accelerated directly past
one's head with earsplitting cracks.
I shall never forget the brain splitting
shockwave is mortar bombs detonated
northern rending of the atmosphere when
a stick of Nebo War for bomb straddled
one slit trench,
my memory is stocked with smells,
the metallic stench of
dead cattle and Normandy.
The pungent odor of German prisoners
and the vial penetrating chemical smell
from a newly proud shell crater.
Strange fleeting memories too.
Okay.
Why in circumstance of great danger did
the palms of my hands moistened making
it difficult to grip
the butt of my pistol.
Why on Pitch Black Knights full of menace?
Was it possible to discern enemy movement
by fixing my straining eyes slightly
to its side? It sounds foolish,
but I swear that it works.
After 40 years,
I am sure I could still prime a 36
grenade in total darkness or load the
magazines of a cult automatic pistol.
I remember our dead
okay.
Their souls departing,
they lay awkwardly like
bundles of discarded clothing.
Okay.
At bed. Berg, lance corporal Porteous
laid by their railway crossing
in an instant. He had gone leaving
his body clothing and equipment
empty
at Helvin.
Boom,
private Jones died with a tiny cry Boston,
the chill winter air as the
bullet took him from us.
Memories are not all sad.
Rarely since as my adrenaline
flowed as an invents to combat
with all the senses.
Alert one lived for a few hours,
sometimes for day at a concert pitch
like a drug. It captivated
me. I wanted more
totally absorbed, one pressed on
until objectives had been seized
and I flopped as I had never done since.
I remember the mood of
pulsating expectancy during
the last few hours before
battle.
Old trusted friends like Dennis Clark
and Brantley Hancock would arrive to tie
up their artillery support.
Others troop commanders from the Sherwood
Rangers would appear almost in party
mood to marry up with us.
Very air was a vibrant with excitement
and good fellowship, no acrimony,
simply an exercise and willing
cooperation to help us.
The infantry overcome the days grim task.
But my most treasured memory is the
simple and sincere affection which existed
between us all
based on mutual trust.
It was the cornerstone of the platoons
success and it survives unchanged.
To this day.
This is tinge to with regret,
regret because Jim Kingston,
Owen Cheeseman,
and particularly Doug proctor,
did not receive any recognition
they so richly deserved.
Jim and Owen were mentioned in dispatches,
but Doug was left on rewarded.
Over the years.
This omission has troubled me,
particularly because I had not
been so had I not been so young and
inexperienced, more notice might have
been taken of my representations.
I have no doubt that they all learned a
military metal on more than one occasion
and I, their platoon commander
failed them. In this respect,
I miss my soldiers.
The warmth of their presence comforted
me and their humor restored my spirits
in the brutal world.
If infantry warfare,
although few of them realized it
and certainly none would admit it,
their behavior was noble.
Their absence left a void,
which,
but for an exceptionally happy marriage
would have certainly drawn me back into
the army for the comfort
that only a soldier can understand.
Strangely, I have never since
considered myself anything but
a soldier.
And that
wraps up that book.
And I'm not
sure if I have much to add because,
because Sydney Jerry seems to capture it.
And so much of what he talks about
explains
so much,
not only about about being a soldier,
but also about what it's like
when a soldier is no longer a soldier
to,
to miss the adrenaline,
to miss that singular focus,
to
miss seeing men
at their best,
at their noblest,
to miss the men themselves,
your comrades,
your friends,
your brothers
to miss what he calls so perfectly that
simple and sincere affection that exists
in a platoon
they'd affection that I'm not
sure exists anywhere else.
And you, you hear me talk about when
I start talking about a seal platoon
about how that's the best
thing in the world. And Sydney,
Jerry captures it better than me.
You miss the mission and you miss the men.
And of course you miss
the fallen
as the British,
call them the glorious dead
and you wonder what would
have become with them.
Where would they be now?
And do you wonder why?
Why them?
Why was it down?
And you know,
I talk about
the gift, right? The
gift that they gave us,
that the fallen if given us this gift
of freedom and this gift of life.
But there's,
there's more,
there's more
because you see
the rest of us,
we grow old
time passes us by.
And that that's simple and sincere
affection that Sydney Jerry describes,
it changes
as we change.
Yeah.
It ages
as we age,
but the fallen do not change
but fallen, do not. Age.
Time has no effect on them.
They remain
babe.
Remain young and bold and
brave and unconquerable.
It's so we remember them
that way
as they were.
And as they will always be.
Tara heroes.
Heroes who walk no more and
yet walk everywhere with us.
Okay.
Who smile no more.
And yet they never stopped smiling
heroes who lived no more yet never stop
living
car.
Friends
who shine no more
and yet never stopped shining.
And that is the other
gift that they give us.
The fortunate
to bask in their lighting.
Do don't remember.
Okay.
I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So reco maybe a frog,
you can talk about something
else for a little while.
Yeah, I would appreciate it.
Sure. You know, apart that
kind of stood out and we talk about this
before where there was a part where,
you know the Germans,
the bandits,
they were attacking 150 yards
away and they just get mowed down.
They just keep killed and then
the red flag comes up,
stretchers come out, everyone sees
fire. It's kind of like, you know,
they're following these specific rules.
Yeah.
And then so they collect the buddies and
they salute kind of like, okay, we're,
we're good. And then he
salutes back. Okay, solid.
No game on essentially game on now.
But this is like a war though.
You know, it's different.
I mean you kind of get that same
feeling way on a lower level obviously.
But like your watch,
like a UFC fight and then the round
ends and then the guys kind of like bump
glove for sure. Good round. Do you
know for sure, but two seconds ago you,
you guys are trying to knock the guy out.
You know, just like in this situation,
two seconds ago these guys were coming
to kill you and you killed them,
killed them,
boom.
It happened round over.
You know,
let's essentially continue
following the rules and it,
it's weird,
it's less about
the rules and more about like the
respect, you know, it is. And,
and on top of that you can pile on the
fact that when they were in Hoven Woods,
the Germans had booby trapped the,
the British bodies.
So they were just laying there.
They didn't get, they didn't get,
they didn't get the same respect back.
But I think that's one thing that,
that Sydney, Jerry is very
intense on throughout the book,
is that regardless of how
deprived the enemy acts,
they are gonna take the high
road. Yeah. And you know,
I think that's why this book is this book.
They give this book to everyone at, uh,
at Sandhurst, which is the, the British
military academy that gives everyone,
I think that's our great reason why,
because he sets a standard with his
troops and they hold that standard through
regardless of the way the enemy behaves,
they don't lower themselves
to that behavior. You know,
the worst atrocity that gets committed
by his soldiers is when they spank a
Waffen ss guy on the
ass. You know, that's,
that's why this book is so powerful.
And, and you know, there's a lot of,
the book is very, it's
very, you know, there's,
there's stuff in there that you
just aren't ready for. Right.
Um, even when he was talking about the
traits that someone should have, and you,
you know, when you start
thinking about it, he's right.
He's right.
And if you had the choice between getting
some meat head that was going to go do
your bidding, even though he might look
like a big beast and he's going to,
but then if you think about how's that
guy going to act when things get tough or
when things become ethically challenging,
how's that person going to act?
So these are
[inaudible] and I love
the fact also that men,
he's killing people. He's the, you know,
it's easy to get caught up in the fact
that he's wearing corduroy pants and he's
got this, there's a part,
there's another part I didn't,
didn't go over in the podcast,
but there's,
there's a group of,
of um,
German, there's a German, uh,
some kind of artillery piece and an
artillery team and they're getting the,
the Brits are getting their guns dialed
in to the team and they're going to
start killing them and
they make a run for it.
And they have horses and there's like
six guys and some horses towing this dis
artillery piece away. And
Sydney, Jerry feels happy.
He's happy that the especially
happy the horses, like you know,
he doesn't like seeing the, the,
the, the animals get killed.
And so he's actually happy that these
guys escape. And then he just says,
you know,
well that's wrong because these guys are
gonna come back and kill my soldiers.
So he does a,
he,
you can see how hard it is for someone
to be in these situations where you have
the good conscience,
which wants to do right thing.
And at the same time you got
to kill people and that's,
that's what makes combat so hard.
And He'd been kind of get you thinking
back, I remember the Christmas,
the Christmas,
Christmas where the Germans,
the Germans kind of in that situation
they initiated that right there.
They were like, cause like a mutual
initiation but yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you remember that particular story.
But I think overall it was almost
like a mutual initiation. But yes.
And that particular story, there was sort
of a voice that says, hey, yeah, I'll,
okay, I won't cheat you or
whatever. And Yeah, man.
It's just crazy how that can
kind of emerge from these
situations where guys are
just straight up getting blown to pieces
on purpose, by the way. Not, you know,
not like some tragic accident
like this is, that's the intent.
That's the intention.
And then they want to just stop
and sing together, plays soccer,
and then the next day,
by the way,
they're going back to killing
each other on mass. Yeah. Dang.
Yeah. That's, that's the thing
about, you know, the Yam,
you know this,
a book like this is so revealing of human
nature because business people have to
do the same thing. Yeah. You know,
if you're a business person and your
business is losing money, well guess what?
You might have to do cut staff.
You know, if you got to, you know,
let's say we're working with a small
business, you've got a small business,
you've got 20 people, you know
all those 20 people. Yeah.
It's not like a nameless person
that you're firing. Right.
When you let go four or
five people because you need
to save money next quarter
or you're going to lose your building.
Guess what?
You're going to know those people.
Yeah,
and so it's the same
dichotomy where this boss,
who wants to take care of
his people just like Sydney,
Jerry wants to take care of his men,
and all of a sudden the only way to
do your mission is you got to kill it.
You've got to,
you're going to get some of these people
guilt or you're going to fire some of
these people.
Otherwise our plant shuts down.
Otherwise we can't go forward and
everyone dies. No one has a job now.
So the similarities,
again, that's why it's,
that's why these things about war
reveal so much about human nature,
which is really what
this podcast is about.
It's about human nature and the
better you understand human nature,
there's two things that can happen.
Number one,
the better you can lead other people,
but equally as important
if not more important,
is if you understand human nature,
you can understand yourself. Yeah.
Can understand the decisions
that you're making.
You can understand why
something's bothering you.
You can understand what you
need to conclude so that
you can move forward in the
best possible way. And if you don't
understand human nature, you're your,
I mean that, that's the
understanding yourself. Yeah.
And these books allows you to gather
it and Garner so much of that. Yeah.
Especially all the
similarities. So many, all
the time.
I remember in junior high,
yeah,
it was junior high. Oh,
maybe early high school.
So when are you split Pop Warner football?
Where my best friend played for a
different team, but we're all, you know,
in pop Warner it's different. It's not
by school, it's by like region, you know,
like we're not region, I guess
town live on coy and no regions go.
I don't think anyway, still the, you
know, my best friend at the time,
his name is Byron, he, uh,
who became a pilot by the way,
I think. Yeah. Army or
Marines, I forget. Anyway. Um,
he played for a different team,
but we were best friends.
So it was kind of that thing, you know,
where you're friends with the guys,
but then you know,
you go in the battlefield and you've
gathered battling and you're back to
friends. It's weird. You're not killing
him though. No Way. Different. Yeah.
Did you ever see that in Iraq?
Like any of that? Like I dunno,
compassion, you know, it did. Yeah, for
sure. Even with the enemy titan, not,
not so much with the enemy type stuff.
So what I mean,
but with the civilian types for
sure. I mean, I mean obviously,
and you'd see guys would go completely
out of their way to try and protect the
civilian. Uh, the enemy
over there is a lot.
It's different. Yeah.
There's a, there's, you know,
here you have a uniformed soldier. Yeah.
There you don't have a uniform soldier.
You got somebody that's trying to sneak
around and blow you up on an IED and
yeah, you don't see that
same level of now. I mean,
once you get a guy captured, that's it,
you know? Okay. We've got him captured,
zip them up, put them in the back of
the Humvee. I mean, that's it. Yeah. So
you definitely,
what what he talks about is this,
this mutual respect of like,
look,
we're sitting in a slit
trench getting mortared.
And when I like when I meet you,
you're on the other side,
but I know that you'd been slipping in
the sitting in a slit trench getting
mortared all day. That's why we have
a mutual respect for each other. Yeah.
In Iraq it's asymmetrical warfare.
So they're not suffering the
same type of situation. Yeah.
And they also, you know, one thing that,
that really throws that stuff out the
window is the way that the insurgence
treated the civilian
populace. You know, so,
so we're witnessing nonjudicial murders.
Like when w executions,
we're seeing that we're seeing civilians
getting tortured, we're seeing, you know,
people being beheaded.
And so when you see that you're
there trying to help these people,
and you start to think,
look,
if you're another infantry men
and an opposing army, I can,
I can empathize with you. I can
understand what you're going through.
But if you're, even if you're
another army, but I see you raping,
torturing, murdering, burning people.
I don't empathize with you anymore.
It doesn't work that way. So
not really. Yeah, makes sense.
Now you wouldn't get,
occasionally you'd get like you could
tell that someone would be mixed up in
something that they shouldn't have been
mixed up in maybe a young kid, you know,
maybe a 17, 18 year old cause
cause some of those kids,
some of the insurgents were
not the [inaudible] Lee,
you know, pro al Qaeda. Some
of them were just, hey look,
I'm going to get paid 50 bucks to put an
IED in the road. My gig. Yeah. Yeah. And,
and if you paid me 50 bucks to go
and plant, you know, crop over there,
I'd just as soon do that. Yeah. So you'd
see some of that, there'd be, okay,
look this, this kid's just, you know,
he just caught up in stuff that doesn't
understand. And then again, I mean,
all I think again,
the dichotomy is if you're putting an
IUD in the road to kill Americans, bro,
I don't care about you. I
want to kill you. Yeah. Um,
that's all there is to that.
And
it's definitely a different
scenario when the,
when the people that you're fighting or
are the ones that are committing
these kinds of atrocities.
Cause even as these guys,
you know, they, they,
you'd see how you differentiate between
like the Waffen ss and like a normal
infantry group. He differentiates
those two. Yeah. That'd be like if,
let's say the war in Iraq was against,
let's say al Qaeda had taken over Iraq
and you were fighting give a hardened al
Qaeda guys or some normal, you know,
infantry men for the Iraqi army. Yeah.
Those guys, you would have been like, hey
look, this dude surrendered. Okay. Yeah.
The Al Qaeda guys, first of all,
they're probably not going to surrender.
And if they do, that's they're going
to knock at the same treatment that a,
that a guy that's a victim
of circumstance, right.
Lot of the Germans are a
victim of circumstance. Hey,
this guy came into power.
I was a soldier. I'm
still a soldier, you know,
and Ah man,
just heavy it is.
But there is a definitely a
mutual respect that you have for,
for another servicemen that's,
you know,
has been through the same kind of crap
that you've been through. Yeah, yeah man,
it makes sense.
So with that speaking a
heavy lifting kettle bells
anyway, I feel like we should talk about
on it on a Greek kettle bells again,
I do feel spoiled even every time I
pick them up, even though they're dope.
You know the,
the artistic ones,
should we call them artistic cause they
have names, right? Primal bells. Yeah.
Just call him that legend bells.
Yeah.
All that stuff.
You know,
I feel kind of spoiled because they're
kind of like the designer once their
designer ish balanced by the way you,
the way I got into that.
Um,
here's the thing about the car,
and I said this before,
starting light with kettle bells critical.
My friend Anthony came over,
I don't know if you remember Anthony
was there the first day we recorded,
he was at my house. Oh yeah. So he came
over the other day and he was like, yeah,
yeah, let's lift. And you
know, last time I seen him,
I wasn't so much into the kettle
bells. So I was like, all right,
we're doing this thing. Be
careful. And I saw him and he had,
I don't think he'd ever
done it. No, but he just,
he grabbed the latest one and you know,
I said start light or whatever.
And you could tell his,
I'm gonna say this with all due respect,
if you haven't done it before,
it makes sense.
But like his form was way off and I'm
thinking, Bro, you're going to get hard.
Okay. Careful. Yeah.
So I wasn't going to go into
like what crazy workout I did,
but I'll save that for another time
for three hours right now or no,
I just looked at my watch to
53 that's not a good sign.
So I apologize to everyone in the
world for doing a three and a half hour
podcast, which isn't going to turn into a
faculty, describes his last 14 workouts,
four and a half hours.
Great detail nonetheless.
So we'll credit krill oil real quick.
I was talking to somebody at the muster,
I think it was,
I forget who it was,
nonetheless was talking
about the benefits yet again,
this is like a common thing.
It's true.
I don't exaggerate about the
Krill oil is still kind of like,
I can't go back to not taking krill oil.
Krill oil and I don't mind.
Oh actually we were talking to life.
Remember he ran out of crow? Yeah,
and he's all mad at me because he gave
me some, I didn't bring any. Yeah,
actually technically, technically it
was Jenna Lee who brought me some.
I think I just gave the order
nonetheless. He gave me. Yeah,
so I guess he and I had a part of it.
Got The credit. He'll nonetheless,
I'll never go back to no krill oil. So
where would you get it on it? Krill oil.
What if you wanted to save money?
Go on it.com/chocolate there's a lot
of things on there and on it is one of
those good companies slash
website where anything you need,
like anything you need supplementation
with all the way down to workouts.
They got it on there.
Try your best not to get too addicted
to the website because it's very vast.
Very rare. The only person that
has that issue, I don't think so.
I will guaranteed spend time like
watching the videos and stuff,
browsing the products. Sometimes you
can get like we talked about the,
you know how you get on
Amazon and you're like, yeah,
I want to get that thing too. You don't
really need, it just looks super cool.
It's one of those websites was on does
that? Yeah. So be careful. It does,
but I don't think it had like prompts you.
It's just the list of stuff is all cool.
You know, it's not just a kettle bell,
it's the really cool
one, you know? So it's,
it's that situation anyway on
it.com/chocolate if you want the 10% off.
And um, yeah, report back.
Tell me what you think and if you asked
me about the Krill oil, I'll tell you,
I'll tell you till the end of time.
I will not not take krill oil ever again.
If I have anything to say about it.
Another way to support is when you pick
up your copy of 18 platoon or whichever
books you choose that Jocko
reads on this podcast.
Go on our website,
Jocko,
podcast.com go to the book section
on the top says books from episodes.
Click through their heads up. If you're
looking to get 18 platoon the book,
you actually, you can get
it on Amazon used. Yeah.
For like 40 bucks and used copy,
which they'll all be gone. Yeah,
yeah. By the time chilling,
whoever you are listening to this,
you can also get it from a website rifles,
direct.com which actually supports
the rifles regiment in the UK.
So, um, you can get it there as well.
Or you can buy the used to hardcover
copies from amazon.com after you click
through, click through
there, boom. And you know,
even if you're a buying something else,
hey,
click through support the cause anyway.
Another way,
subscribe to the podcast on
Itunes, stitcher, Google play, and
any other podcasts providing platforms
also and not excluding youtube.
Youtube is a good one video version. I
got youtube red by the way. Hey, wait,
wait.
What's the benefits again of the,
one of the benefits is on youtube
rep you can listen to you.
Even if you go to another APP,
it's still playing. So it's a real,
it's a real cool deal for me.
I'm in sounds [inaudible] I liked to add.
I know you do.
That's relevant most of the time unless
you see the same ad over and over and
again, you don't have to, you know when
they play, you ever see the same oil,
you don't see ads anymore.
No.
But there's who may or may not enjoy ads
and or still have the older person that
enjoys ads. You guys, she must, you know,
you know how it like here for example,
so ty Lopez,
right?
He'll have like ad every single time.
I know you know that there's this other
financial company, which is a weird one,
which is really, it's a really
poorly done nonetheless. So ty Lopez,
he was the example. Ty
Lopez, he'll be like,
he'll talk about some stuff and then
after it's the same ad over and over and
after awhile you're like,
okay, okay, skip the ad.
But then it kind of sticks with you
and then you're kinda like, yeah,
that's called advertising sucked
in. Yeah. But it's kind of like,
I see what's going on yet. I still
am compelled, you know? So it's like,
it's kind of like, it's beneficial
almost. I'm over here not compelled,
compelled fill. No. Anyway,
I am compelled to to subscribe
to Youtube. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
There you go.
So we're trying to say you're sending
a lot of other stuff going on.
Go on these tangents and it's relevant.
I feel like people can relate on some
level, sometimes. Maybe occasionally,
maybe weird people nonetheless.
Youtube. That's a good video version.
What's the, uh, what's Jocko
podcast is the channel. Yeah.
[inaudible] yeah, sure. It'd be cool
if you put videos on there more often.
I do just before I put like two or three
a week. Oh yeah. Two, three weeks now.
Kind of. Okay, good. I'm looking
forward to that new, whatever.
I pick number one on the other. What
does Monday? Yeah. Okay. That's one.
It's whatever it is right
now. Thursday. No worries.
I got you. Good. Subscribe to
that if you haven't already.
And you can get the video version and
excerpts which are sharable, sharable,
meaning they're just shorter and shorter.
So you know,
whoever opens it,
they ain't going to be more of a chance.
I'm going to listen to it when it's two,
three minutes long rather than two and
a half, three and a half. In this case,
hours long.
That's just how fired from doing
podcasts cause they're too long.
Is that possible? Maybe.
Hmm. I guess how these else,
anything is possible, right?
That's the thing. Um, what
else? Uh, Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store
website, Jocko store.com. See?
Catchy, right? Easy to remember.
If it's a store and it's
jock was his chocolate store.
If it's a podcast and it's [inaudible]
is Jocko podcasts, if it's, you know,
if it's key chains.
I was meeting some peach key chains,
some people talking to some people
at a group the other day. Sure.
We're not familiar with
me or with anything.
Good respect. And they, they said,
oh well do you, you know, one of
them said, oh he's got a podcast.
And then the other one said, oh, what's
the name of the podcast? And I said,
all the podcasts is called Jocko podcast.
And she said,
this one girl said, did you pay your
marketing team a lot for that day?
And I said yes. In fact, I did
exactly real original like that. Yup.
Original but hey man could be worse.
So back to the store,
Jocko store,
that is some tee shirts on there.
If you want to represent, uh,
you know the tee shirts carry a
message. The message has layers.
Actually,
I guess technically the shirts have
layers because the message is one of the
layers of it. The shirt anyway, go on
there and store.com if you like something,
get something that's a good way to
start wars shirts coming out this week.
That's my question to you. That's the
intention. I'm getting angry. Yes,
I understand. I understand. But no, make
me not in your business. Normal face,
normal face.
My face is way normal.
The don't make me come and get in
your business and do your job for you.
Because if you've ever heard
me talk on this podcast,
I talk about when people don't
do their job, that's awesome.
Cause then I can take their
job from them. Right, right.
You got to step down and think about
where I'm more of my mindset is.
And you may want to step it up
over on a year end all. Dang.
You're about to jump into the song. I,
yeah, yeah, yeah. None. No respect. I am.
I dig it and we're gonna try to get
that shirts for, you know, let's,
do you know why you're
saying this right now?
Because you can't wait for the
shirt that you designed to come up.
Also, I think you're, I
think you might be, um,
really sabotaging and
sabotaging my efforts.
I made the better shirt.
Uh Huh.
And you don't want to print it because
you're self conscious and that's not
going to stand well.
I will give you the respect because
there is in fact layers to this shirt as
well, so. All right. How about this? More
layers. More layers you, oh yeah, yeah.
You could be right. I think you might have
more layers than the standard, I guess.
We'll see. We're going to find out about
that one. Anyway, Jocelyn, start icon,
so women's stuff on there as well.
Some patches, some rash guards,
some cool rash guards. Yeah, indeed.
Hoodies, other stuff. Anyway,
go on there. Check it out. If you
want something, get something.
Good way to support. Also psychological
warfare. If you're having trouble,
if you're having trouble,
if you're like me and sometimes you stew
or currently having trouble with not
feeling like working out,
not feeling like it,
so you're considering skipping
the workout, waiting for tomorrow,
making your workout day into a rest day.
If you're having that problem,
this is what you do. Go psychological
warfare, search on iTunes, Google play,
Amazon, Amazon, all these things
anyway where you can get mp3s,
you search psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink,
and it's an album
with traffic
and these tracks will help you
through anything that you're feeling.
That weakness,
like I just mentioned,
whether it be waking up early or skipping
the workout or cheating on the Diet
and I say cheating on the Diet because
you made a promise to yourself,
you're not going to eat those donuts.
You made a promise and then now
like all of us eat the donuts. No,
that's not the promise you made. Just
like I can never eat a doughnut again. No,
sure. Exactly right. You can't,
everyone in the world will like,
someone will get better there with a,
with a camera and they'll get me
and consider this like what if you knew
100% no one's watching or whatever and
then you're eating the doughnut. Can you
imagine the guilt? You're feeling guilt.
Yeah, he can't do it. You're done.
Don't, not to too much guilt,
but in the event of other people,
not you dropped with other
people feeling that weakness.
There's the track for that.
Remember back when I phone Kinda
came out and there's that thing.
There's an APP for that.
Remember that used to always say that,
oh there's an app for that. There's an
APP for that. That was like an expression.
See, look with this. There's a
track for that. Jimmy was saying,
just made that up right
now. Anyway, psychological
warfare, check it if you need,
if you need that, that spot
because really that's what it is.
It's a spot in life when you're
trying to lift heavy things.
It's good to have a spot if you're
lifting light or not lifting at
all. You didn't need a spot,
so don't even worry about that.
If you're not doing nothing, don't
even get this. You don't even need it.
If you're not doing anything in life,
don't get it. You see what I'm saying?
Makes Sense, right? I'm get
it. Exactly right. All right.
Like I said, 18 will tune.
You can get that at rifles, direct.com
from the UK. It supports that regimen,
which I'm all about. Also, you know,
speaking of rash guards and stuff,
check out origin main.com my boy up there,
Pete Roberts,
these kind of these kind of
psycho actually kind of a mad man.
He's all about manufacturing in America,
which I'm all about too,
and I'm going to go into this,
but at some point,
but like he wanted to make gies
here and he couldn't get the fabric,
so he went out and bought old abandoned
looms from abandoned factories.
I had hired like old timers that knew
how to work these things and refurbish
them and rebuilt them
and has made these looms,
brought them back to life so that he
can make gies and rash guards here in
America in Maine. And like I
said, that's kind of crazy.
Borderline psychopathic,
which I kind of like and
that's kind of why we're,
we're kind of working on
joining forces in some way.
A P origin.
Warpath it's going down.
We're going to make something happen.
I'll keep everyone informed
as we finalize the plan.
That rash guard that you mentioned and
posted the video that was a lot nicer is
a lot. Oh yeah, Easter and legit. I,
when you see it, it's underplayed it.
You're like, yeah, well
you didn't know I made it.
I made it sound like just kind of cheesy.
Yeah.
Like you didn't realize
it was actually sad.
But the thing is that rash guard,
it's our, I had already sold out.
I know. So now he's printing a
bunch more but, but he's got,
he's got a weave the material.
Yeah. Yeah. Right. Or it gets,
he gets one of his producers here in
America. We have materials. So anyways,
check out that origin
main.com growing company.
We're getting in league
with them big time. Um,
also Jocko white tea on Amazon.
Here's a,
here's an actual, again, this
is a certified verified report.
I have a cat that used to catch
one or two mice per month.
I forgot to pick up the tea bag after I
brewed it and the cat ate the tea bag.
Now my cat is bringing home raccoons,
full grown rabbits and even the
neighbor's dog. So be careful.
Don't let your cat get it unless your
neighbor's dogs being annoyed. No,
that's Jocko white tea. You can have it
and it's not, it doesn't take the thing.
It doesn't taste like normal tea.
It tastes like victory. All right.
Way The war, your kid. Boom. Also,
this is a warning about
way the warrior kid.
When you order way of the warrior kid,
just go ahead and also order a
pull up bar, some flashcards,
some healthy food, edit, Jujitsu G.
Cause when your kid gets
done reading this factually,
if they're going to want to be
stronger, better, tougher and smarter.
So supply them the way
they need to be supplied.
Quit playing around.
Get some.
Also the discipline equals
freedom field manual.
There's no book like this doesn't exist.
It is not a normal book.
It's kind of like the podcast.
This podcast is not for everyone.
Not everyone wants to listen
to this podcast. That's okay.
I'm not making a podcast for everyone.
We're making a podcast for
people that like to get after it.
So this book is not for
people that want to read, um,
junk. Sure. Some people
don't get the podcast.
Some people aren't going
to understand the book.
They're not gonna know where it's
coming from. That's okay. I'm not,
I'm not,
I'm not towing.
We're not toning down the podcast right
now. We're not saying, Oh, you know what?
I think everyone would like it more if
we did more, you know, interspersed some,
some jokes throughout it and maybe if
we made it 45 minutes and do the little
fun presentation and can I get some
backup music just to kind of have little
jangled to make people get in the spirit.
We're not doing that.
Not Happening. If you want to listen to
a little jangle or a little, you know,
metallic riff to get you in the zone
on the beginning of the podcast,
that's cool. Then if you
want that, that's awesome.
There's other podcasts that offer,
we don't offer it here.
You know what you're going to get with
the book if you're looking for, you know,
um, 50 shades of gray and
you're not going to get that.
It's a,
but that's the cool thing.
The cool thing is that the publisher
let me do whatever I wanted to do.
So I did and I made the gear and to
feel you're going to feel that the,
that the feeling of the podcast is the
same feeling that the book gets you.
So it's a little heavy,
little dark, right? Sparse,
right? Sure. Get after it.
That's in there anyways.
Discipline equals freedom
field manual order it. It's,
it's not printed. I'll give you
an looming give you an example.
It's not printed on white paper,
so the straight up,
let's just go from there.
It's actually printed.
The background is all images,
black and white images.
I know that comes as a big surprise to
everyone for sure and then put over that
his words. So there you go.
Little indicator as to what the,
the field manuals like you
can get that good preorder it.
Now of course extreme ownership.
It's a little book.
It's about leadership actually.
It's about combat leadership and how
you can take the combat leadership
principles that we learned on the
battlefield and apply them to your life.
You can get that book too if you want it.
We also have echelon front consulting
me, Leif Babin, JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
We will come and help your team align
your leadership so you can crush your
enemies.
You just heard Sydney Jerry saying it.
A leadership is the thing that makes you
overcome seemingly impossible things.
So if your leadership isn't squared away,
you're not going to overcome them.
So you need to get in the game.
You can contact us info at echelon,
front.com if you want that.
Okay.
Also the monster. We just got back
from the Austin Muster. Outstanding.
Outstanding. It was awesome. So many
great people in their lessons learned.
Knowledge spread.
Okay.
Tim Kennedy was there.
Tim Kennedy showed up. Uh,
and it was cool and I didn't
realize it until we were at Jujitsu.
And I think I came up to you
and said this during Jujitsu.
So the last night we have Thursday,
then Friday and then Friday night we go
do Jujitsu. We went to 10th planet at, uh,
Austin, Austin, 10th planet Jiu
Jitsu with my boy Curtis Curtis.
Todd White was there and
Todd White, right? Yeah.
He's an old school. Like he's, me
and him are from that same era. Yeah.
We're, we're from the same era. From
back in the day only. He's only,
he's a better artist. A better
artist than me. Yep. So well,
we went in and what I realized is this,
you don't like a way the
warrior kid, people say, aw man,
I wish I had that book when I was a kid.
Yeah. And extreme ownership. People say,
aw man, I wish I had that. I wish I
had that book when I started out in my,
you know what I got
promoted five years ago.
And you know what I say
about way the warrior kid.
I wish I had it when I was a kid. You
know what I say about extreme ownership.
I wish I had it when I was a assistant
platoon commander. I wish I had it. Yeah,
I didn't have it.
And what's cool about the monster is so
that feeling when you go to the monster
you're giving dislike or just given
this massive amount of inflammation,
pragmatic information that you can
take and you can execute with. Yeah.
And so when we were at
Jujitsu, I realized, man,
we just all this stuff,
these people in this room just
got all this information and it,
and it's so practical that you
can take back to your team.
And then on top of all that,
here's a little something
else. Jujitsu. Yeah. Because,
um, well only one quarter of the people
that came to Jujitsu had ever trained
Jujitsu before the other,
what was 50 people that
had never trained before.
So they're getting this gift, the
gift of Jujitsu in true. Yeah. Little.
And they all, I would say 50% of them
will go back and start training. Yeah.
Maybe more. I wish it was
100% yeah, it might be. It
might be. Yeah, it'd be, yeah.
It depends on what you're
into your, yeah, it's hard.
It was always bizarre to me that when
I introduced to someone as a Jujitsu,
it was a 100% conversion rate.
It should be a 100% conversion rate.
100% Oh, you just choked
me and I couldn't stop you.
I need to learn that a hundred percent
otherwise I go through life vulnerable to
being choked by anyone. I don't
like that feeling. Yeah. No,
I don't like that the
muster two is sprinkled in.
I don't and I mean heart sprinkled hard
by the way, which is a very critical,
compelling part in my opinion
is this the social stuff.
And I don't mean social like you're
just cruising and not learning.
I mean the people you meet.
Oh yeah.
Well you definitely are going to meet
good people there because everyone there
is in the game big time and
they're all looking to get better.
They're all invested to get better.
And, and the other thing is,
you know we're hanging out. I ha I see all
the time. Yeah, no there's me. Lafe Dave,
Jp Echo. We're not, there's no
green room. It doesn't exist.
We don't even take breaks.
Just like when,
when we take a break to let the audience
like go to the restroom or grab a,
you know a cup of coffee
or Jocko white tea. We,
we just, we just stand there like
we stepped down office agent,
we get everyone lines up
when we talk questions.
And you know what I was doing
this time was I was like,
instead of answering one person's
question, just to that person I was going,
hey everyone career,
cause he's asking a question that everyone
coming over a nearby, there's, there's,
there's 12 people standing in line. Yeah.
Instead of answering this one question,
this one guy whispering,
know,
hey everyone come up here and you
can all hear this because who knows,
maybe there's some of those questions.
Maybe it's something we're gonna
experience in the future. I don't know.
But you might as well listen and maybe
you have a better solution than I have.
Yeah. So it's like a, like a little
little brainstorm brainstorm, right? Yeah.
Yeah. It's cool. That's true.
You, we take breaks. Everyone.
There's break throughout the
known you take bricks, Jacqueline,
don't take breaks for us. Break
time is talk ties, talk to you guys,
sign a book, whatever. No
Green Room, no green room.
So that's the muster. Um, and by the way,
they've sold out all of them that
we've done have been sold out.
Now the next one that we got coming up
is September 14th and 15th back at the
Omni Hotel in downtown San Diego,
California.
Muster zero zero four it's gonna sell out.
This is a known fact,
so if you want to come,
it's September 14th and 15th.
That is right around the corner.
So if you want to come to that,
come to that extreme ownership.com is
where you can register if you want to.
Also my,
the way this is interesting,
if you train Jujitsu or if you're
interested in training, Jujitsu,
origin up in Maine has this
immersion camp that they do.
I'm going echo's going with me.
We're going up.
There it is.
There's two sessions that they run.
It's the 20th August 20 the 23rd or
August 24th through the 27th those are the
two different sessions or you can
come for the whole week. Anyways,
I'm going to be there for those middle
three days, like Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday.
So I'm going to be there for the last day
of the first camp and the first day of
the law of the second camp and
it'll be on there on the Middle Day.
We're going to be training, rolling,
talking, hanging out, eating lobster,
eating steaks, uh, just
generally getting after it.
So you got to origin main.com
if you want to come up.
There's not a lot of spaces for that.
They, it's, it's, it's not, that's like,
I think the most they're
going to go is 200 people.
So that's not a lot of spaces.
So if you want to come up,
register quick and I'll see you guys
up there in Maine. I'm going to,
what I like about it is unlike the
muster where everything is scheduled,
like we don't have a lot of break time
and even the break times we're working
this thing. I mean you can only train
Jujitsu what, six hours a day maybe.
You know what I mean? Two hours in
the morning, two hours at lunch,
two hours in the evening. So
that's six hours. You know,
you're going to sleep four hours.
So you still got 14 hours left in the day.
So what are we going to do? We're going
to kick it. Yeah. We're going to cruise.
There's a lake,
there's Kayaks,
there's a zip lines
and whatever. Yeah. Oh,
we'll just go lay in bed and try and
recover from the Jiu Jitsu sessions.
So yeah. Um, a bunch of good people
coming up renewed after that.
If you want to come up and hang out,
do it.
And that will work.
We'll see you up there either at the
muster or we'll see you at the immersion
Jujitsu camp. How do you register
for that one? Origin main.com.
And then you click on the
immersion thing and you'll find it.
You Press Google, figure it out. Yeah.
Yeah. There's a certain element of like,
if you can't figure it out, don't bother.
Yeah. And there's also a certain
element of like, Hey, register now and,
and go to this thing today, register
today. And they always think today. Yeah,
I know. They say that today. By
the time this podcast comes out,
it won't even be today.
So,
uh,
all right.
Also until we're at one of those events.
If you want to roll with us virtually,
we are on the interwebs,
the Twitter,
the Instagram, the Facebook, keep watch.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally thank you to everyone
for listening to this podcast and for
supporting this podcast,
which by the way is made possible by our
military who protects our great nation
from evil.
This podcast is made possible by police,
law enforcement, firefighters, EMT,
first responders that keep us
safe and orderly here at home.
And it's made possible by each and every
one of you out there working in the
economy,
making and creating and building.
So don't stop doing that
and don't
ever stopped remembering
those that went before us,
those that still shine down on us and
remember that we are not here long,
then time is fleeting.
It is ever fleeting.
So you might as well make it a good,
hard run,
then get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.